j'informe que des candidatures pour
siéger au sein de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées de la commission des
affaires sociales la commission des lois
ont été publiées ces candidatures seront
ratifiés si la présidence n'a pas reçu
d'opposition dans le délai d'une heure
prévue par notre règlement l'ordre du
jour appelle la discussion du projet de
loi de finances rectificative adoptée
par l'assemblée nationale pour 2022
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à monsieur bruno le maire ministre
de l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur leur apporte en général
monsieur le ministre un mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je suis très heureux de vous retrouver
ici au sénat pour l'examen du paquet
pouvoir d'achat sur son volet projet de
loi de finances rectificative
nous avons franchi une première étape et
je tiens à vous en remercier avec
l'adoption du projet de loi pouvoir
d'achat je tiens à vous remercier pour
la qualité des débats qui ont permis
d'adopter un texte qui est attendu par
tous nos compatriotes je souhaite
évidemment que nous puissions avancer
dans cette même atmosphère constructive
lors de cette discussion du plfr
dans quel contexte ce que cette
discussion se tient d'abord dans un
contexte économique dans lequel
l'économie française résiste nous venons
d'avoir les chiffres de la croissance le
deuxième trimestre +0 5% pour le
deuxième trimestre 2022 la france
obtient avec ce chiffre un des meilleurs
résultats de la zone euro et ce résultat
de 0 5% prouve que l'économie française
résiste mieux que les autres économies
européennes aux turbulences économiques
actuelles il confirme également que
comme l'avait annoncé le gouvernement
l'économie française atteint diane gr
bien les 2 et 12 5% de croissance en
2009 à 2 2 c'était l'objectif que nous
nous étions fixés
et je crois que pour tous les français
pour tous nos compatriotes pour toutes
les entreprises c'est une victoire
obtenue dans des temps difficiles
l'inflation continue dans ce contexte
économique difficile de progresser et
nous sommes bien comme je l'avais
indiqué il ya quelques mois au coeur du
pic inflationniste
l'inflation reste à un niveau élevé et
elle restera à un niveau élevé jusqu'à
la fin de l'année 2022 en revanche
je confirme que nous continuons à
anticiper une baisse de l'inflation dans
le courant de l'année 2023 grâce à la
réorganisation des chaînes de valeur à
la diversification des
approvisionnements en matières premières
auquel nous travaillons avec les autres
mini sous l'autorité de l'après ministre
du président de la république et grâce
aux effets de la politique monétaire
ce pic inflationniste donc un cap
difficile à passer qui justifie toutes
les mesures d'accompagnement qui vous
sont proposées aujourd'hui
quelles sont ces mesures sans rentrer
dans le détail de chacune d'entre elles
je voudrais expliquer la philosophie et
la teneur des mesures qui vous sont
proposées aujourd'hui il ya d'abord tout
un volet qui porte sur l'énergie c'est
légitime parce que la moitié de
l'inflation au moins s'explique par la
flambée des prix de l'énergie
l'électricité le gaz ou les carburants
nous avons donc décidé de maintenir le
bouclier énergie jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2022 avec le gel du prix du gaz
et le plafonnement du prix de
l'électricité à 4% ces décisions qui ont
été prises à l'automne 2000 21 explique
que la france est aujourd'hui le taux
d'inflation le plus faible de la zone
euro nous avons anticipé et nous avons
pris des mesures massives qu'ils ont
permis de combattre avec efficacité
l'augmentation des prix je rappelle
également que nous allons évidemment
continuer à nous battre au niveau
européen pour dissocier définitivement
le prix de l'électricité du prix du gaz
ce système européen dans lequel le prix
de l'électricité décarbonée est indexé
sur le prix des énergies fossiles c'est
à dire sur le prix du gaz est un système
inacceptable du point de vue écologique
est complètement contre-productif
d'un point de vue économique il a
également un coût social qui le rend
insupportable
nous avons engagé cette bataille avec à
présent la république depuis plusieurs
mois nous ne lâcherons jamais rien
jusqu'à ce que le prix de l'électricité
décarbonés soit définitivement dissocier
du prix du gaz
toujours sur l'énergie des propositions
ont été faites à l'assemblée nationale
sur la question du fuel 3 millions de
nos compatriotes se chauffent au fioul
était donc légitime et je salue la
sagesse des députés de prendre des
mesures fortes sur le fuel et la
compensation pour nos compatriotes de ce
chauffage au fioul nous avons donc
adopté une aide de 230 millions d'euros
pour les ménages qui utilisent ce
combustible pour se chauffer je confirme
que nous lèverons le gage sur ses 230
millions d'euros et que nos compatriotes
auront bien 230 millions d'euros à se
répartir pour amortir le choc de
l'augmentation des prix du fuel je
propose que les parlementaires du sénat
et de l'assemblée nationale soit associé
à la définition de ciblage des ménages
qui pourront bénéficier de cette aide
supplémentaire 3 millions de nos
compatriotes
une enveloppe très significative de 230
millions d'euros faut-il la cible est
sûre qu'elle ménage l'un plutôt que de
discuter uniquement entre membres du
gouvernement je propose que les
parlementaires soit associée à ce choix
politiques de la répartition de
l'enveloppé des 230 millions d'euros en
faveur de trois millions de nos
compatriotes
troisième sujet toujours sur l'énergie
c'est le prix des carburants est
probablement ce qu'il y a de plus
visible et de plus sensible pour nos
compatriotes aujourd'hui l'assemblée
nationale a proposé de passer la
ristourne sur les carburants à 30
centimes d'euro en septembre de 18
centimes 30 centimes en octobre 10
centimes en novembre et 10 centimes en
descend je sais que d'autres
propositions toutes intéressantes et
argumentée ont été formulées par les
sénatrices et les sénateurs je pense
néanmoins qu'il est sage de s'en tenir à
la solution retenue par l'assemblée
nationale qui a le mérite de couvrir
tous nos compatriotes y compris les
retraités y compris ceux qui ne
travaillent pas je suggère donc que nous
retenions cette proposition qui fait que
avec les remises accordées par certains
pétroliers ou par certains distributeurs
nous pourrions avoir un prix du
carburant à 1 euro 50 à la rentrée de
2020 deux hauts lieux des prix que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui je pense que
beaucoup de nos compatriotes attendent
désormais très concrètement d'aller à la
pompe est d'avoir ce chiffre là je
recommande donc nous en tenons à cette
solution pour tous ceux qui me disent
légitimement qu'il faut faire plus pour
ceux qui travaillent je rappelle que
d'autres dispositifs seront mis en place
nous avons accepté notamment à
l'assemblée nationale le doublement du
plafond d'exonération la prime carburant
versées par les employeurs qui va passer
de 200 à 400 euros or c'est précisément
une prime qui ne vise que les salariés
que les personnes qui travaillent nous
avons également deuxième mesure pour les
personnes qui travaillent permis le
cumul de cette prime carburant avec la
prise en charge de l'abonnement
transports collectifs pour tous ceux qui
dans les territoires ruraux prennent
leur voiture pour aller jusqu'à la gare
puis de la gare prennent le train pour
aller jusque sur le lieu de travail et
qui aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas cumuler
l'indemnité carburant avec l'indemnité
transports collectifs grâce à la
décision de l'assemblée nationale
désormais ils pourront cumuler les deux
c'est une deuxième mesure prise très
précisément en faveur de ceux qui
travaillent et qui prennent leur
véhicule pour aller travailler
enfin troisième mesure où je tiens à
citer nous avons revalorisé le barème
kilométrique de l'impôt sur le revenu de
10% en 2022 et je confirme que nous
sommes prêts à revaloriser à nouveau le
barème kilométrique de l'impôt sur le
revenu en 2023 avec ces trois mesures
qui ciblent spécifiquement les personnes
qui travaillent je pense que nous
pouvons conjuguer réduction du prix du
carburant à la pompe pour tous les
français et renforcement de ces mesures
pour tous ceux qui travaillent et qui
sont particulièrement pénalisées
troisième grandes orientations de ce
projet de loi de finances rectificative
le travail nous avons la conviction avec
gabriel à thann avec l'ensemble des
membres du gouvernement que la meilleure
réponse au problème du pouvoir d'achat
c'est l'emploi c'est de travail c'est la
juste rémunération du travail cela a été
le fil rouge de notre action politique
pendant cinq ans cela restera le fil
rouge notre action politique pendant les
cinq années qui viennent jusqu'à ce que
nous atteignons ce qui n'a pas été en
francs atteint en france depuis un demi
siècle
le plein emploi le plfr vise donc à
rendre du pouvoir d'achat à nos
compatriotes par la valorisation de leur
travail grâce à des mesures très ciblées
qui ont été complétés par un certain
nombre d'amendements de certains groupes
présents aujourd'hui première mesure la
monétisation des rtt je vois bien le
débat qui a émergé à la faveur de cette
proposition soit monétisation des rtt
mais je vous confirme que nous estimons
que permettre aux salariés qui
souhaitent travailler plus d'augmenter
leur rémunération en monétisant leurs
rtt nous paraît une mesure juste
efficace et qui mérite d'être retenu la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires l'idée de relever le
plafond d'exonération fiscale de 5000 à
7500 euros va dans la bonne direction et
je vous confirme que nous sommes prêts à
rendre cette défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires porté à 7500 euros
définitive et il me semble que le
caractère définitif de cette mesure
garantira là aussi sa justice et je le
dis pour ceux qui s'inquiètent sur les
rtt c'est le complément de cette mesure
pour que l'ensemble des personnes qui
souhaitent travailler puissent être
mieux rémunérés ça restera notre
philosophie et personne n'arrive à me
convaincre qu'il vaut mieux inciter les
français à travailler moins et à gagner
moins il me semble que de ces temps de
difficultés il vaut mieux travailler
davantage et avoir la juge des
rémunérations de son travail j'attends
avec impatience débat qui nous permettra
d'échanger sur ce sujet
même chose sur les heures
supplémentaires
le groupe l'est républicain a proposé
que nous avancions encore plus loin sur
les heures supplémentaires en demandant
à ce que les entreprises puissent voir
leurs charges sociales patronales
réduites elles le sont déjà pour être
tout à fait précis de 1 euro 50 pour les
entreprises de moins de 20 salariés
le groupe a proposé que pour les
entreprises de 20 à 250 salariés je le
dis devant le président retailleau il y
ait à nouveau une réduction de 50
centimes d'euro n'existe pas aujourd'hui
pour alléger le coût pour les
entreprises qui sont des pme 20 à 250
salariés j'estime que c'est une idée
constructive utile pour le pays à
laquelle je suis favorable
quatrième sujet les collectivités
locales je suis ici dans l'assemblée des
collectivités locales
ça ne m'a pas échappé ce à un coût
nécessairement je sais que l'inflation
et que les revalorisations qui ont été
engagées peuvent susciter des
inquiétudes mais je rappelle que les
députés dans leur grande sagesse ont
déjà commencé à tenir compte de l'impact
de l'inflation sur les collectivités
locales et que le gouvernement qui sans
doute n'avait pas fait suffisamment sur
le sujet a accepté de faire davantage à
l'occasion des débats à l'assemblée
nationale notamment à l'initiative je le
dis pour le groupe socialiste de madame
christine pires bonne nous avons porté
preuve que le gouvernement est cuménique
nous avons accepté 180 millions d'euros
de dispositifs ciblés qui va s'adresser
aux 6000 communes qui sont les plus en
difficulté qui peine à faire face à la
hausse du prix de l'énergie est à la
hausse du point d'indicé les
collectivités d'outre-mer sont
particulièrement concernés par ce
dispositif je sais que vous y êtes
sensibles et je sais que nous aurons
d'autres discussions sur le sujet nous
avons également accepté de compenser la
hausse du rsa pour les départements nous
avons eu de longs débats sur le sujet
nous avons accepté une compensation de
120 millions d'euros ce qui fait au
total déjà 300 millions d'euros de
compensation pour les collectivités
locales confrontées aux conséquences de
l'inflation sur le prix de l'énergie ou
sur le prix d'un certain nombre de
fournitures je suis certain que ce débat
ne s'arrêtera pas là et se poursuivra
ici avec l'ensemble des groupes je veux
vous dire ma disponibilité à faire
encore plus attention aux collectivités
qui en ont réellement besoin pour
bénéficier de ce filet de sécurité
je le dis devant le rapporteur général
qui je le sais
particulièrement mobilisé sur ce sujet
mais je sais aussi que j'ai ici devant
moi une assemblée de sénatrice et de
sénateurs aussi attaché comme moi à la
bonne tenue des comptes publics et qui
savent que pour bien tenir les comptes
publics il faut demander des efforts à
tous à l'état aux dépenses sociales mais
aussi aux collectivités locales tout
n'est pas possible financièrement ni
pour l'état ni pour les collectivités
locales ni pour les dépenses sociales
j'appelle donc chacun au sens des
responsabilités pour que nous ayons une
enveloppe qui protège les collectivités
locales mais qui ne menace pas nos
finances publiques
enfin il ya un sujet qui a défrayé la
chronique depuis plusieurs semaines qui
est le sujet de la taxation des supers
profits
je me méfie des termes la taxation par
définition et les super profits parce
que je pense qu'il recouvre des réalités
qui sont bien différentes et je sais
qu'un certain nombre d'entre vous
notamment le groupe de l'union centriste
ont déposé des amendements sur ce sujet
je veux dire d'abord que je comprends
j'imagine que d'autres bancs dans cette
partie de l'hémicycle l'ont fait
également sinon je serais surpris et
voir pour tout dire le fond de ma pensée
déçu
je veux dire d'abord que au risque de
vous surprendre
je comprends le raisonnement que vous
amener à faire cette proposition
car j'imagine bien que ce raisonnement
est d'abord dicté par un souci de
justice
et que sous ce souci de justice qu'il
soit sur les bancs de droite aux dépens
de gauche de cette assemblée trouvera
toujours avec moi son plus fervent
soutien
il faut partager le fardeau de
l'inflation et je ne laisse jamais
contesté et j'ai toujours dit communiste
l'économie et des finances que ce
n'était pas à l'état tout seul de porter
le fardeau de l'inflation nous avons
déjà fait beaucoup notamment avec le
bouclier énergétique
les ménages vont évidemment beaucoup
parce qu'ils supportent une part de
cette inflation dans leur vie
quotidienne bah il est légitime que les
entreprises porte elle aussi une part du
fardeau de l'inflation mais je voudrais
rappeler c'est là que je me méfie ces
termes un peu brutaux de taxation sur
les super profits seraient rappeler que
l'immense majorité des entreprises des
petites entreprises et pme des tpe des
indépendants souffre de l'inflation
elles vont augmenter le prix de leurs
intrants elle voit augmenter leurs prix
leurs approvisionnements elles ont des
délais dans leur approvisionnement
elles sont lésés par le prix des
matières premières elles ont dans
l'hôtellerie dans la restauration dans
la distribution dans l'industrie
agroalimentaire des difficultés de
recrutement comme elles n'en n'ont
jamais connu tenant compte aussi des
difficultés de nos entreprises je
voudrais également rappeler que lorsque
vous regardez les négociations
salariales vous apercevez que beaucoup
d'entreprises participent à la lutte
contre l'inflation que la meilleure
façon pour l'entreprise de participer à
la lutte contre l'inflation c'est pas
d'être taxé c'est augmenter les salaires
de leurs salariés et je veux redire ici
avec beaucoup de force que toutes les
entreprises qui le peuvent toutes les
entreprises qui ont les moyens plus des
entreprises pour les marges nécessaires
doivent augmenter les salaires et toutes
celles qui ont des inquiétudes en me
disant légitimement mais on ne peut pas
se projeter au-delà de quelques mois on
redoute ce que va être l'année 2023 on
ne veut pas s'engager tout augmentation
de salaire je peux entendre ça mais je
dis à ces entrepreneurs vous avez des
instruments pour augmenter la
rémunération de vos salariés sans
menacer la survie d'autres entreprises
ça s'appelle la participation ça
s'appelle l'intéressement ça s'appelle
la prime défiscaliser utiliser ces
instruments qui augmente la rémunération
sans affecter la survie de l'entreprise
en revanche quelques entreprises
effectivement font des bénéfices
importants et elles doivent participer à
l'effort collectif mais elles doivent y
participer comme le font c'est ma cgm
total ou angie en rendant l'argent
directement aux français plutôt qu'aux
trésor public et je pense qu'il est plus
juste plus efficace
plus conformes aux convictions de cette
majorité de procéder de cette manière là
que de céder à nouveau au réflexe
pavlovien kahn si vous voulez je
m'attelle à ce taux
une hausse entre ea je ne crois pas que
ce soit conforme à votre adn politique
que de multiplier les taxes et les
prélève cette approche que nous
proposons elle est plus juste car elle
ne pénalise pas les entreprises que vous
allez tout frappé de manière
indifférente quelle que soit leur
situation par une taxe qui les couvrira
sans exception elle est plus efficace
car elle va directement dans les poches
de nos compatriotes 20 centimes de
remise à la bombe cela mettra le prix du
carburant à 0,50 à la rentrée et je
pense que nos compatriotes préférons
voir un litre d'essence 1 euro 50 à la
rentrée plutôt que de lignes du trésor
qui est abondée grâce à une nouvelle
taxe à la fin de l'année 2022 enfin
c'est plus conforme à notre ligne
politique car cela va dans le sens de la
baisse des impôts et cela favorise
l'attractivité de notre territoire et à
tous ceux qui me donnent sans cesse
l'exemple de la grande-bretagne de
l'italie qui ont taxé superprofits
j'aurais juste rappeler que e.on des
industries productrices notamment la
grande bretagne qui extrait du pétrole
en mer du nord et que ces pays là on de
10 à 15 points de prélèvements
obligatoires de moins que la france
quand on est le pays le plus taxé de
tous les pays européens on ne rajoute
pas une taxe supplémentaire à toutes les
taxes qui existe déjà
enfin
nous vous proposons
nous sommes d'ici pour débattre
chers collègues nous sommes le lendemain
les orateurs des groupes s'exprimeront
tout à l'heure j'attends qu'ils soient
et quelle chose qui menacera délinquant
si je calme c'est l'ennui et je sais que
sur les bancs du sénat il y aura des
débats qui sont animés s'agit pas de
faire des meetings politiques mais il ne
s'agit pas que la démocratie ton dans
l'ennui dans le respect de la
considération de chacun ayons la volonté
d'exprimer avec force et conviction nos
arguments c'est ce qui rendra notre
débat intéressant pour nos compatriotes
enfin nous proposons la suppression la
contribution sur l'audiovisuel public
qui rendra à 138 euros de pouvoir
d'achat aux ménages qui l'a aussi j'en
suis certain animera notre débat public
cette décision est conforme à notre
politique constante de baisse des impôts
nous avons travaillé un dispositif de
financement durable de vie duel public
qui est un gage de son indépendance
j'espère que nous parviendrons là aussi
à un équilibre constructif sur ces
sujets je voudrais enfin vous remercier
de votre présence aujourd'hui nous
sommes le 1er août le débat assez
prolongées très tard dans l'été donc
vous voyez que c'est toujours avec
beaucoup de joie que je suis présent
dans cet hémicycle pour discuter
dialoguer avec les amis sénateurs
bon
allez on va se calmer ça sert à rien je
vous rappelle qu'il ya après le débat il
ya 450 amendements donc on a prévu cette
nuit la nuit prochaine va peut-être
faire ça calmement 1 je salue d'abord la
préside la présence du président du
sénat parmi nous et j'appelle monsieur
gabriel attal ministre délégué auprès du
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle
lesnumeriques chargé des comptes publics
à s'exprimer
monsieur le président de séance monsieur
le président du sénat monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
ministre depuis deux ans face aux aléas
aux incertitudes aux soubresauts notre
réponse n'a jamais varié à grand défi
grands moyens pendant la pandémie nous
avons assumé l'installation de puits
sans amortisseur le quoi qu'il en coûte
à inspirer l'investissement inédit d'une
puissance publique
résolu à sauver les entreprises à
préserver les compétences des salariés à
protéger le pouvoir d'achat en
investissement saluée par les
économistes mais aussi par les français
et notamment par la france des
entrepreneurs des artisans des
commerçants qui a redécouvert que l'état
et en particulier l'état providence
était aussi là pour eux ce choix de la
protection nous l'avons fait sans jamais
perdre de vue notre boussole la
préparation de l'avenir par delà les
crises nous n'avons jamais cessé d'agir
avec deux lignes de force majeure la
valorisation du travail et la transition
écologique et énergétique
or nous n'aurions pu ni protégé sur le
moment ni préparer l'avenir si dès le
début du précédent quinquennat nous
n'avions pas remis de l'ordre dans nos
comptes c'est parce que notre pays a
regagnée sa crédibilité en repassant dès
2018 sous les 3% de déficit public que
nous avons pu emprunter pour protéger
les français au moment où sévissent est
la copie c'est parce que notre pays est
sorti de la procédure pour déficit
excessif à bruxelles que nous avons
regagné une certaine crédibilité en
europe et plus convaincre nos
partenaires de déployer un plan de
relance historique
face au retour de l'inflation face aux
difficultés de la vie chère pour nos
concitoyens nous continuons à agir pour
les protéger nous continuons à prendre
des mesures pour être à leurs côtés et
pour chercher au maximum à amortir ce
coût de l'inflation pour les français
nous le faisons en maintenant le cap
fixé il ya cinq ans emporté par bruno le
maire et nous poussons encore davantage
les moteurs de notre stratégie moins
d'impôts moins de dette plus de
croissance nous le faisons avec deux
lignes de force qui je le sais
résonneront particulièrement dans cet
hémicycle la recherche du compromis et
la responsabilité la recherche du
compromis elle est bien connue dans cet
hémicycle malgré ma très jeune
expérience en la matière j'ai pu mesurer
à chaque fois que j'ai eu à défendre des
textes doit travailler sur des textes
dans cet hémicycle que nous parvenions à
trouver des compromis au service de
l'intérêt général entre des groupes
différents faisant partie de la majorité
ou de l'opposition et je suis persuadé
qu'il en sera de même dans ce débat la
responsabilité c'est celle de continuer
à préserver nos finances publiques et
j'ai entendu ces dernières semaines un
certain nombre de déclarations qui ont
été formulées notamment dans la majorité
sénatoriale sur l'importance de tenir
nos comptes et de rester sur une
trajectoire de réduction des déficits
qui est un enjeu absolue de crédibilité
un enjeu aussi de pérennité pour nos
services publics nous maintenons donc
notre cap et les français le voient
c'est pour cela que ce plfr est un plfr
de stabilité et de dignité stabilité de
notre politique économique et dignité
car face à l'inflation nous ne mettons
pas davantage la tête des françaises
sous l'eau par le poids des impôts qui
augmentent nous les aidons à vivre quand
la vie devient trop cher
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
texte que nous vous présentons
aujourd'hui traduit donc un effort
massif pour un défi d'ampleur cet effort
massif de 44 milliards d'euros se
décompose en trois blocs des crédits
budgétaires pour protéger aujourd'hui le
pouvoir d'achat des français
des crédits budgétaires pour continuer
de préparer l'avenir des crédits
budgétaires enfin pour honorer nos
engagements financiers et financer
l'alourdissement de la charge de la
dette ces trois blocs traduisent donc à
la fois l'ambition qui est la nôtre et
le cadre dans lequel nous agissons qui
est un cadre contraint ainsi et
contrairement à ce qu'indique son titre
projet de loi de finances rectificative
ce texte n'est pas le reflet d'une
trajectoire que l' on rectifie ou d'une
ligne que l'on corrige à la marge mon ce
texte est impuissant réacteurs au
service des français de notre économie
de notre cohésion il est le moteur d'une
stratégie visant à permettre aux
français de dépenser moins et de gagner
plus
dépenser moins pour l'énergie à la
maison grâce à la prolongation du
bouclier tarifaire jusqu'à la fin de
l'année bruno le maire l'a rappelé
dépenser moins pour se déplacer grâce
aux crédits que nous ouvrons pour
accompagner les français en la matière
dépenser moins en payant ses impôts avec
la suppression de la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public les débats à ce
sujet seront nourries mais il me semble
que les garanties que nous avons
apportées avec celle que nous pourrons
toujours ajouter dans le cadre du débat
nous permettront de vous convaincre
gagner plus avec le financement des
revalorisations des prestations sociales
des retraites ou de la rémunération de
nos fonctionnaires gagner plus également
avec les avancées qui ont été adoptées
par l'assemblée nationale pour valoriser
celles et ceux qui travaillent dans
notre pays je pense notamment au
relèvement à 7500 euros du plafond
d'exonération des heures supplémentaires
ou encore à la possibilité de monétiser
les rtt ou non le maire le disais à
l'instant certains parmi vous notamment
dans la majorité sénatoriale propose de
pérenniser ces dispositifs est
évidemment fidèle à l'esprit d'ouverture
et de compromis que nous avons est
particulièrement engagée sur la
valorisation du travail nous serons
évidemment très attentifs et réceptifs à
ces propositions ce texte répond donc
aux chocs d'aujourd'hui mais il gère
également préparer l'avenir je le disais
en maintenant tout d'abord notre
trajectoire budgétaire car un pays qui
ne tient pas ses comptes ne peut être
demain un pays libre et fort préparer
l'avenir également en renforçant notre
souveraineté industrielle et la
transition énergétique avec le
financement de la prise de contrôle à
100% d'edf et la prolongation du bonus
écologique pour les français qui change
de véhicules préparer l'avenir en
modernisant notre rapport avec les
entreprises et en luttant contre la
fraude avec la facturation électronique
pour les entreprises s'agissant de la
lutte contre la fraude là aussi je sais
que la majorité sénatoriale porte
notamment un amendement visant à lancer
la carte vitale biométrique là aussi
nous y sommes favorables préparer
l'avenir aussi en luttant en continuant
à agir pour l'emploi avec des crédits
supplémentaires pour l'apprentissage 1
milliard 800 millions d'euros pour
france compétences et près de 750
millions d'euros pour les primes
d'apprentissage ces chiffres reflètent
le dynamisme de cette politique une
réussite majeure du quinquennat
précédent avec plus de 700 mille jeunes
en apprentissage alors qu'ils étaient
moins de 300 milles en 2017 au cours de
l'examen de ce texte nous aurons des
échanges des débarras des discussions
sur un certain nombre de mesures ou de
paramètres ces débats témoigneront d'une
chose nous avons tous la volonté de
répondre présent pour protéger nos
concitoyens face au choc économique
mondiale que nous traversons
mais il y aura je crois au coeur de nos
débats plusieurs grandes questions qui
émergeront première question ce choc
conjoncturel doit-il nous conduire à
priver nos services publics et notre
modèle social des ressources
indispensables à leur pérennité en
adoptant soit des baisses de taxes
d'impôts pérenne massive et non ciblés
qui ne changerait pas la vie des
français seconde question de choix
doivent pas nous conduire à nous priver
de toute marge de manoeuvre pour
continuer à préparer l'avenir et
investir vous savez nous répondons par
la négative à ces deux questions parce
que nous devons la vérité aux français
et la vérité c'est que la guerre en
ukraine nous a fait changer d'époque
inflation forte croissance plus faible
nous estimons désormais que le pib
devrait croître de 2 5% en volume cette
année la croissance résiste comme l'a
dit bruno le maire mais nous sommes
conscients des aléas qui existent au
niveau mondial la vérité c'est que nos
finances publiques sont à risque en
raison de l'inflation et de la remontée
des taux d'intérêt la charge de la dette
que je rappelais au début de mon
intervention s'élèvera cette année à 17
milliards d'euros supplémentaires en
comptabilité nationale c'est
l'équivalent de deux fois le budget du
ministère de la justice il faut le dire
clairement la parenthèse de l'emprunt
gratuit c'est bel et bien refermée et
toutes les décisions que nous prenons
qui ont pour conséquence d'alourdir les
déficits et la dette sont prises dans ce
contexte là il faut toujours l'avoir en
tête c'est pourquoi nous préférons
toujours des mesures ciblées et
temporaires qui réponde véritablement à
des difficultés constatées sur le
terrain en clair nous sommes passés du
quoi qu'il en coûte ô combien ça coûte
c'est à dire de la logique presque
inconditionnel qui a prévalu au plus
fort de la crise du coc vide à une
approche plus ciblée plus juste et donc
plus efficace tout en étant soutenable
pour les finances publiques à ce titre
je le dis ici nous réaffirmons notre
objectif
maintenir le déficit de nos
administrations publiques à 5% cette
année et le ramener en dessous de 3 %
d'ici à la fin du quinquennat nous
assumons de tenir les comptes de tenir
les comptes pour respecter nos
engagements de tenir nos comptes pour
conserver notre indépendance pour
préserver une force de frappe une force
d'investissements budgétaire face aux
grands défis que nous devons affronter
vous en déduisez donc les lignes rouges
que nous refuserons toujours de francis
de franchir dans ce débat laisser filer
les comptes et augmenter les impôts je
vous disais au début de mon intervention
que nous nous trouvions dans un moment
charnière ce texte est capital capital
du fait du contexte dans lequel il
s'inscrit capital par les moyens
financiers exceptionnels qu'ils mettent
en oeuvre capitale parce que pour la
première fois nous supprimons un
deuxième impôts en cinq ans avec la
réforme du financement de l'audiovisuel
public alors que le texte initial
faisait le choix d'un financement au
travers de crédits budgétaires le groupe
majoritaire de l'assemblée nationale a
opté pour l'affectation d'une fraction
de tva ce mode de financement étant
considérés comme offrant davantage de
garanties pour les sociétés
audiovisuelles et leurs salariés je sais
que le débat aura lieu ici tout à
l'heure comme il a eu lieu à l'assemblée
nationale il ya quelques jours je sais
qu'un certain nombre d'entre vous
considère qu'il faudrait consulter
davantage je veux rappeler qu'il y a eu
énormément de rapports énormément de
travaux qui ont été menés notamment dans
cette assemblée je pense notamment aux
très bons rapports hugonnet karoutchi
qui a été remis
il ya quelques mois
il ya eu des rapports auparavant
monsieur assouline tout à fait il ya eu
des rapports multiples il ya eu des
travaux multiples et tout le monde
s'accorde sur le fait que la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui est
obsolète injuste et datés et qu'il faut
donc la supprimer et donc nous aurons ce
débat mais je le dis c'est un débat
important
de la même manière je souhaite que nous
puissions trouver nous souhaitons et
bruno le maire trouver le bon point
d'équilibré s'agissant de la réponse à
adopter aux demandes de soutien des
collectivités locales fragiles dans le
contexte d'inflation sur les prix de
l'énergie de revalorisation du point
d'indicé du rsa je veux rappeler comme
là c'est bruno le maire que le mécanisme
de ce filet de sécurité qui a été
introduit dans le texte à l'assemblée
nationale est une traduction complète
contre concrète de l'esprit de dialogue
qui nous a mine qui nous anime la
rédaction de l'article iv terre est en
effet le fruit d'un travail engagé avec
l'ensemble des groupes politiques qui
ont en bonne intelligence conforter
l'amendement proposé par la députée
socialiste christine pires bonne je sais
que de nombreux amendements émanant de
l'ensemble des groupes ont été déposée
sur ce sujet j'espère que notre débat
permettra de définir les bons critères
permettant de cibler les collectivités
qui ont besoin d'un soutien sans
constituer une charge démesuré pour le
budget de l'état et en ayant en tête que
nous aurons rendez vous au moment du
projet de loi de finances pour aborder
de manière plus structurelle la question
du financement des collectivités locales
ce qui nous rassemble aujourd'hui c'est
l'urgence l'urgence pour les français
qui connaissent le plus de difficultés
l'urgence pour les collectivités qui
connaissent le plus de difficultés je ne
crois pas que ce soit le moment du grand
débat sur le financement des
collectivités locales nous avons un
projet de loi de finances pour cela
dernière illustration et j'en termine
par la de cet esprit de dialogue
l'assemblée nationale a voté une
dotation de 10 millions d'euros pour
soutenir les collectivités en matière de
titres sécurisés et nous savons que
beaucoup de nos concitoyens peine encore
à pouvoir bénéficier d'un rendez-vous
pour renouveler leur carte d'identité ou
leurs passeports après discussion avec
plusieurs sénateurs dont le rapporteur
général jean françois husson qui a
déposé un amendement tendant à renforcer
le dispositif
nous pensons avec bruno le maire qu'il
est justifié
renforcer ce dispositif et nous
soutiendrons donc l'amendement porté par
le rapporteur général lui sont sur les
collectivités locales comme sur tous les
autres sujets faisons en sorte de
définir ensemble le meilleur dispositif
en ces sens d'opposer finances locales
et finances de l'état car à la fin il
n'y a qu'un seul contribuable ait qu'un
seul site concitoyens celui que nous
avons le devoir de servir je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant monsieur jean françois husson
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances pour dix minutes vous avez la
parole de ceux le rapporteur général
monsieur le présent monsieur le
président du sénat monsieur le présent
la commission messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues nous pensons tous je
crois que l'état doit apporter son
soutien à ceux qui sont confrontés
à ce nouveau contexte des prix qui
s'envolent depuis quelques mois et qui
touche aussi bien nos concitoyens que
les entreprises et les collectivités et
singulièrement les plus fragiles parmi
ceux là tel est notamment l'objet de ce
projet de loi de finances rectificative
depuis la crise sanitaire la france
semblent s'être habitués à une réponse
permanente des pouvoirs publics à chaque
crise or il faut trouver le bon niveau
de dépenses sans risque et d'entretenir
l'inflation ou de rendre ensuite plus
difficile le financement de nos dépenses
dans un contexte de hausse des taux et
de renchérissement de la dette sans
oublier l'état de nos finances publiques
qui continue de se dégrader de manière
préoccupante
le ministre des comptes publics vient
encore de déclarer qu on serait passé du
quoi qu'il en coûte ô combien ça coûte
selon moi le combien ça coûte monsieur
le ministre ça coûte aussi cher avec
déjà 40 milliards d'euros consacrée aux
réponses apportées à l'accélération de
l'inflation cette année avec le risque
que cela dure encore un certain temps
le texte qui nous est soumis prend acte
de la dégradation de la situation
économique depuis décembre avec
effectivement une
prévision de croissance du pib qui
baisse de 4 à 2 et 10 % alors qu'elle
pouvait paraître plus optimistes les
bonnes nouvelles sont arrivées il faut
le dire de l'insee vendredi dernier avec
une première estimation de croissance au
deuxième trimestre 2022 plus rassurante
et qui donne du crédit à cette prévision
mais j'observe que la consommation des
ménages continue de baisser et que les
indicateurs conjoncturels sont au plus
bas je note aussi que le fmi vient de
réviser sa prévision de croissance pour
2023 de 1,3 à 1% il nous faut donc
rester prudent
le projet de loi de finances
rectificative traduite aussi le contexte
inflationniste dans lequel nous évoluons
et qui contribue non seulement à
dégrader la consommation des ménages et
l'investissement des entreprises et par
suite nos perspectives de croissance
mais également à accroître le niveau des
taux d'intérêt et notamment ceux des
obligations souveraines
dans l'ensemble les mesures prises par
l'état bouclier tarifaire remise à la
pompe indemnités inflation ont eu des
effets positifs sur l'évolution des prix
et le revenu des agents
néanmoins ces résultats montrent
évidemment un robert messieurs les
ministres c'est celui de l'aggravation
des comptes publics en clair leur
détérioration
certes le projet de finances
rectificative révise à la hausse les
prévisions de recettes publiques pour
2022 avec 50 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires au titre des
prélèvements obligatoires mais en
parallèle dépenses publiques augmentent
de 60 milliards d'euros
le niveau nos dépenses publiques n'est
donc plus tout à fait en phase avec les
objectifs de la programmation des
dépenses primaires s'établissant à 5 %
au-dessus de l'eau niveau prévu
alors à cet instant je constate que
votre gouvernement laisse filer la
dépense alors même que nous sommes
confrontés au défi tant redouté de la
dégradation des conditions de
financement de notre dette la charge de
la dette le ministre gabriela talent
vient de le rappeler représente cette
année 18 milliard d'euros
supplémentaires excusez du peu
alors l'analyse du seul budget de l'état
il très concrètement la politique du
combien ça coûte du gouvernement ainsi
les ouvertures de crédit de 53,8
milliards d'euros en autorisations
d'engagement et 47,6 milliards en
crédits de paiement sont les plus élevés
jamais réalisés dans un collectif
budgétaire depuis l'entrée de la lolf
c'est donc considérable
les seules dépenses pilotable sont elles
en hausse de 27 milliards d'euros dont
18,1 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
par ce seul projet de loi de finances
rectificative alors je le dis j'ai le
sentiment qu'il n'y a plus de pilote
pour les dépenses de l'état le texte
anticipe un déficit de 177 8 millions
d'euros en hausse lui aussi de 25
milliards d'euros par rapport à la loi
de finances initiale en revanche
l'endettement au titre de 2022 se
maintient
pour autant c'est bien toujours avec une
dette que le déficit est financé à
savoir la dette qui a été contracté il y
a deux ans en 2020 l'état avait alors
dit mentionné ses émissions de dette par
rapport au déficit prévu en milieu
d'année et il s'est avéré moins élevé
que prévu l'état donc conserver cette
trésorerie surabondante qu'il propose
utilisé pour financer le déficit actuel
pour résumer mes chers collègues ce
budget rectificatif prévoit 50 milliards
d'euros de dépenses supplémentaires
financé par 30 milliards de surcroît de
ressources et 20 milliards d'euros de
dettes émises il y a deux ans vous le
voyez les dépenses nouvelles
s'accumulent pour la troisième année
consécutive
or si l'on pouvait espérer que la crise
sanitaire soit temporaire je crois que
ce n'est pas le cas de la crise
énergétique et environnementale qui
s'annonce on verra peut-être le prix des
carburants et du gaz redescendre
temporairement si les tensions
internationales venait à s'apaiser mais
il ne faut pas se tromper c'est un monde
nouveau qui s'annonce auquel il va
falloir nous adapter et où les mesures
budgétaires ne pourront pas constituer
des réponses durables
le soutien du pouvoir d'achat par la
dépense publique a atteint ses limites
et ce sera très prochainement l'heure
des choix douloureux qu'elle dépense
publique voudront nous à quel niveau
quelles priorités fixons nous alors que
nous ne pourront plus financer aussi
facilement par la dette et que la dette
accumulée pèsera elle dans nos comptes
compte tenu de ces éléments vous
comprendrez que ce n'est pas proposé à
la commission des finances de nouveaux
dispositifs qui viendrait s'ajouter à la
liste déjà longue de ceux déjà prévus
dans les deux projets doit pouvoir
d'achat loi de finances rectificative le
texte sorti de l'assemblée nationale
comprend des avancées qui vont dans le
bon sens comme la hausse du plafond
applicable pour la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires ou bien encore la
monétisation des rtt il faut en effet
soutenir les salariés et offrir de la
souplesse dans la gestion du temps de
travail en ces temps de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre
la commission des finances propose
d'ailleurs un amendement qui vise à
rendre pérennes
merci monsieur le ministre pour le la
bienveillante le bienveillante avec vous
avez déjà délivré sur la hausse du
plafond applicable à la défiscalisation
des heures supplémentaires à 7500 euros
soutenir la valeur travail et les
salariés les plus exposés les plus
précaires
c'est également ce qui a guidé notre
choix de remplacer la prime de rentrée
exceptionnelle réservée aux minima
sociaux par une majoration exceptionnel
coup de pouce de la prime d'activité
s'il faut mettre fin à la politique du
chef permanent nous prévoyons en
revanche une rallonge de la
participation financière de l'état à
l'exercice des missions des banques
alimentaires à hauteur de 40 millions
d'euros pour tenir compte des
importantes difficultés qu'elles
connaissent sur le bouclier mis en place
au titre l'énergie nous nous rallions
globalement est ce qui a été décidé
notamment être le soutien pour tous est
plus conséquent par le biais de la
remise carburant je suis aussi favorable
à l'extension du bouclier tarifaires aux
ménages qui se chauffent au fioul et 230
millions d'euros votés à l'assemblée
nationale ne seront pas de trop pour
autant j'estime que nous arrivons
la logique la transition écologique doit
être menée il nous faut recouvrer notre
souveraineté énergétique est l'état de
nos finances publiques ne nous permettra
pas de poursuivre ainsi au delà de la
fin de cette année aussi par exemple
cette mesure sur le fuel doit-elle être
ciblés pour représenter un soutien
financier suffisamment conséquent pour
ceux qui en ont besoin éviter le
saupoudrage
nous regrettons vivement la perte de 3
milliards que représente la suppression
de la contribution à l'audiovisuel
public le montant de la tva qui le
remplace sera autant qu'il ne sera pas
utilisée à autre chose et ne peut de
toute façon être affectés que jusqu'à
fin 2000 24 en vertu de la lolf que nous
avons votée sous la pression insistante
d'ailleurs de la précédente majorité
le gouvernement danois dont utiliser les
deux années à venir pour mener une
véritable réforme de l'audiovisuel
public en y associant un mode de
financement efficaces à cet égard les
propositions de la mission menée par nos
collègues jean raymond hugonnet et roger
karoutchi sont sur la table saisissez là
messieurs les ministres vous gagnerez du
temps
enfin concernant les compensations
alloués aux collectivités territoriales
la commission des finances propose tout
d'abord de renforcer le filet de
sécurité issue des travaux intergroupe
de l'assemblée nationale et qui touche
le bloc communal on le fait comment en
assouplissant les critères d'éligibilité
est les modalités du calcul de l'aide
dans la même logique que la compensation
pour les départements de la
revalorisation du rsa nous proposons
également de compenser pour les régions
le coût de la revalorisation des
rémunérations versées aux stagiaires de
la formation professionnelle
enfin
nous continuons de refuser les réserves
de budgétisation que le gouvernement se
constitue
l'expérience de 2021 et les nouveaux
reports de crédits massifs réalisés
début 2000 22 plus de 29 milliards
d'euros les ministres montre que les
pratiques se poursuivre eh bien nous
proposons de supprimer 4 milliards 5 qui
ne nous paraissent pas justifiée nous
ouvrons ainsi en faveur d'une gestion
budgétaire rigoureuse en évitant de
prendre le pli de certaine aisance ou
facilité contraire au redressement
nécessaire de nos comptes publics pour
offrir à la france et aux français un
meilleur avenir je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur général
la parole est maintenant monsieur claude
raynal président de la commission des
finances pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
président du sénat messieurs les
ministres se rapportant général mes
chers collègues le projet de loi de
finances rectificative que nous
examinons aujourd'hui est présenté par
le gouvernement comme le deuxième volet
de son paquet pouvoir d'achat mais bien
sûr il ne se résume pas cela tout
d'abord c'est un collectif budgétaire
qui prend en compte le nouveau contexte
macro économique avec une baisse de la
prévision de croissance de 4 à 2,5 pour
cent et d'importants ajustements en gros
set et en dépenses ce projet de loi
intègre aussi des mesures nouvelles qui
ne sont pas toutes liées au pouvoir
d'achat comme par exemple la suppression
de la redevance pour du visuel public on
en a parlé le report d'un an de la
suppression de la fiscalité spécifique
au gazole non routier ou encore la
renationalisation des enfants surtout il
présente une réponse très partielle aux
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat de certains
de nos compatriotes
l'insee vient d'indiquer que l'inflation
avait atteint en juillet 6 1% sur un an
avant même ces nouveaux chiffres le choc
en 2022 était déjà estimé à 66 milliards
d'euros soit environ 1000 euros par
habitant et 4 3% du revenu des ménages
enfin lieu a calculé que sur ce
important d'inflation général les 10%
des ménages des mieux lotis subissent
une inflation de 2 ans et demi pour cent
tandis que les 10% des ménages est le
plus exposé subissent une inflation de
8,5 la réponse doit être différenciée ce
que ne fait pas suffisamment de ce pv
faire du point de vue des équilibres se
collective aggrave le déficit du budget
de l'état la hausse des dépenses est en
effet très significatif de 44,2
milliards d'euros dont la moitié pour le
pouvoir d'achat ce qui ne compense pas
la réévaluation des recettes fiscales la
charge budgétaire de la dette augmente
dès cette année de 11,9 milliards
d'euros il ne s'agit pas pour moi
évidemment de remettre en cause la
nécessité de soutenir les ménages ou de
renforcer l'intervention publique face
aux défis qui s'annoncent notamment en
matière de résilience et transition
énergétique
je ne peux en revanche que déplorer que
dans la situation particulièrement
délicate que nous connaissons avec des
comptes publics dégradés des
perspectives de croissance incertaines
et une hausse elles certaines des taux
d'intérêt le gouvernement poursuivre sa
politique de désarmement fiscale
aujourd'hui la suppression de la
redevance audiovisuelle créerait un
nouveau manque à combler de 3,7
milliards d'euros et fragiliserait
l'audiovisuel public demain la poursuite
de la baisse des impôts de production
aggraverait la situation de plusieurs
milliards d'euros alors même que
l'essentiel des baisses d'impôts déjà
réalisé ce sont sept sur le dos de la
dette en regard une nouvelle fois rien
n'est proposé pour prélever des acteurs
économiques ayant les plus fortes
capacités contributives afin de
rééquilibrer les comptes aucun projet
d'imposition du patrimoine
alors que les panneaux cumulé au cours
de la crise par les plus hauts des cils
de revenus est très importante
aucune taxation des bénéfices
exceptionnels de certaines grandes
entreprises comment à ce stade de mon
propos ne pas évoquer les résultats des
grands groupes énergéticien français au
premier rang desquelles total triplement
des profits semestriels à 18,7 milliards
de dollars pour une production du même
ordre qu'en 2021 une aubaine de marché
supporté par nos concitoyens comme l'a
écrit valérie rabault récemment comment
peut-on accepter monsieur le ministre
votre propos taxer total je vous cite
n'est qu'une facilité et non une mesure
de justice
il faut oser il faut oser monsieur le
ministre dira que la reprise d'un
bénéfice exceptionnel conjoncturel pour
le redistribuer vers les populations les
plus fragiles de notre pays qui
participe d'ailleurs à la constitution
de ce bénéfice ne serait pas une mesure
de justice et comment mettre en
parallèle quelques mesurettes excusez
moi de le dire ainsi d'un coût de 500
millions d'euros quand même mais bien
mal ciblés alors c'est pas votre faute
c'est la faute de quelques députés ne
citerai pas de l'assemblée nationale
mais bon comment le comparer avec
finalement les 5 milliards à peu près 10
fois plus minimum que cette taxe
pourrait rapporter il est d'ailleurs
savoureux de constater que nos grandes
entreprises argue d'une activité
internationale lorsque tout va bien et
d'un siège social en france lorsque les
crises surviennent de tout cela les
français ne veulent plus quand en plus
total annoncent qu'une partie de ces
profits sera consacrée voyons au
développement non à la transition
énergétique non à l'amélioration des
salaires de ses salariés peut être mais
au moins pour deux milliards d'euros au
rachat d'actions au seul but de faire
monter la valeur de l'action alors oui
mes chers collègues agissons et votons
cette taxe exceptionnelle
merci monsieur le président
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur éric bocquet
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologistes pour cinq minutes
sur le président bush à présent du sénat
mes chers collègues messieurs les
ministres
au soir de sa victoire le 24 avril
dernier le président de la république
avait eu ces mots je le cite ce vote
m'oblige pour les années à venir
ces terres nouvelles ne sera pas la
continuité du quinquennat qui s'achève
la colère et les désaccords doivent
aussi trouver une réponse il faut enfin
considéré toutes les difficultés des
vies vécues et les difficultés qui se
sont exprimés fin de citation nous voici
trois mois plus tard en séance pour
débattre d'un projet de loi de finances
rectificative qui aurait dû marquer le
début de cette ère nouvelle qui nous fut
annoncée par l'oracle de l'elysée du
discours proposition formulée le gouffre
est béant
pendant les deux campagnes du printemps
les fractures profondes qui minent notre
société sont clairement apparu et parmi
les préoccupations de nos compatriotes
s'est exprimée très fortement la
question du pouvoir d'achat
ainsi ce sont 40 % des français qui ne
partent pas en vacances cette année dans
notre pays pourtant sixième puissance
économique mondiale
celles et ceux qui partent constate la
hausse vertigineuse du prix des
carburants qui les privera des petits
plaisirs des vacances la sortie au
restaurant en famille ou la crème glacée
offertes aux enfants au seuil de la
canicule
sans doute c'est l'automobiliste ont-ils
apprécié d'apprendre que le groupe total
energy dont il est beaucoup question ces
jours ci a réalisé un bénéfice net de
17,7 milliards d'euros pour le premier
semestre 2010 22 et que de surcroît on
apprend que ce groupe n'a pas payer
d'impôts en france en 2020 et en 2021 la
fédération française des banques
alimentaires a réalisé il ya quelques
semaines une étude visant à mesurer
l'impact de l'inflation qui vient de
franchir la barre des 6% sur les
personnes accueillies dans le réseau des
banques alimentaires premier réseau dead
mais banques alimentaires viennent en
aide à 2,2 millions de personnes en
situation de précarité
je relèverai 3d constat que cette étude
met en évidence d'abord une hausse du
budget alimentation pour la moitié des
foyers interrogés ensuite une hausse des
prix qui affecte davantage les familles
avec enfants enfin un report massif sur
les produits les moins chers de l'autre
côté du spectre nous évoquions la santé
économique de total energy un groupe qui
n'est pas une exception
l'ensemble des groupes du cac 40 ont
dégagé collectivement quelque
174 milliards d'euros de bénéfices du
jamais vu dans le capitalisme français
et une hausse de 70% par rapport aux
précédents records rapporté une échelle
plus humaine plus accessible au commun
des mortels les groupes du cac 40 ont
gagné
5517 euros chaque seconde
ainsi donc la question des superprofits
at-elle légitimement surgi dans les
débats nous pourrions tout autant citer
mj qui a engrangé des profits record
l'an dernier avec 3,7 milliards le
logisticien cga cgm qui transportent des
conteneurs a réalisé 18 milliards de
profits en 2021 et a déjà encaissé 7
milliards au premier trimestre de cette
année l'italie et le royaume uni cela a
été dit ont tous deux mis en place une
taxe sur les super profits des
énergéticiens hauteur de 25%
d'autres états européens ont suivi le
même chemin à l'évidence en france les
actionnaires sont cajolés dorloter
chouchouter dans le quinquennat
précédent vous avez fait ce choix de
baisser la fiscalité du capital avec la
suppression de l isf et la mise en place
du prélèvement forfaitaire unique pour
les dividendes ces choix n'ont eu comme
effet que de concentrer davantage encore
la richesse puisque les 10% les plus
riches détiennent la moitié des actifs
qui financent l'économie y at il eu au
moins un effet sur l'investissement on
peut en douter
monsieur le ministre vous appeler
régulièrement à la modération en matière
de distribution de dividende s'agissant
du pouvoir d'achat vous demandez aux
entreprises qui le peuvent de faire un
geste à l'évidence ces gestes ne sont
que des signaux faibles souvent très
faible total a annoncé une remise d'été
de 12 centimes par litre valable
uniquement en juillet et en août et
seulement sur les autoroutes la
compagnie de conteneurs cma-cgm offre de
son côté une ristourne de 500 euros sur
les contenir deux conteneurs de l'asie
vers la france à partir d'août et ce
pour un an entre temps nous apprenons
que le pdg de cette compagnie monsieur
rodolphe saadé figure désormais à la 5e
place du classement annuel des grandes
fortunes publié par le magazine
challenges grâce à une augmentation de
sa fortune de plus de 30 milliards
d'euros la source de ces énormes profits
n'est pas on le sait dans l'invention
d'un produit révolutionnaire
l'entreprise bénéficie simplement d'une
situation anormale hors marché de
pénurie et nous devrions nous interdire
de taxer ces supers profits
ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative c'est le gras pour les uns
et quelques miettes pour l'immense
majorité des autres notre société est
fracturée ne l'avons dit et pour
combattre le cancer des inégalités vous
prescrive l usage du paracétamol
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à madame sylvie vermeillet
pour le groupe union centriste pour cinq
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
président du sénat messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances sur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
le plfr 2022 se destine à contenir la
hausse des prix et protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages le groupe union
centriste souscrit à cet objectif et
proposera plusieurs mesures chaque fois
ciblée car il a bien retenu monsieur le
ministre le maire votre message d'il ya
un an la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte et
le soutien à ceux qui en ont besoin il y
à un mois plus sombre vous déclariez
tout n'est pas possible tout simplement
parce que la france a atteint la cote
d'alert sur les finances publiques et en
viennent aussi inquiet que vous nous
sommes très déterminés car la dette est
devenue très chère pour commencer relevé
de 18 à 30 centimes la remise carburant
ne nous paraît pas judicieux pour cinq
raisons 1 contrairement à ce que vous
souhaitez la baisse nos cibles personnes
et touchera tous les niveaux de revenus
elle bénéficiera même deux fois plus aux
plus aisés comme le souligne justement
le conseil d'analysé économique qui
constate que les rabais sont des mesures
inefficaces et coûteuses 2 non seulement
elle bénéficie à tous les revenus en
france mais aussi et c'est encore pire à
tous les étrangers touristes ou
frontaliers comme le disent mes voisins
suisses c'est l'état français qui payent
lorsqu'on laisse un prix de 25 % le
producteur en profite pour remonter son
tarif 4 que se passera-t-il lorsque dans
quelques mois le prix des carburants
remontera de 50 centimes aurons-nous un
nouvel épisode gilet jaune et 10
milliards de dépenses à la clé 5 le coût
pour les finances publiques est
inacceptable car la dette financée ainsi
sans limites ni condition de ressources
ni condition de nationalité
c'est parfaitement contradictoire avec
la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte
à la place de cette mesure dispendieuse
nous proposerons un amendement de michel
canevet prenant en charge une partie des
frais de déplacement des personnes qui
travaillent via l'employeur en
contrepartie de réductions de charges
patronales nous accordons les mêmes 30
centimes de réduction mais seulement à
celles et ceux qui utilisent leur
véhicule pour travailler
toujours soucieux des finances publiques
nous proposerons une contribution
exceptionnelle sur les bénéfices de
l'année 2021 je sais monsieur le
ministre que vous n'y est pas favorable
puisque vous réalisez vous réduisez les
propositions des sénateurs a des
réflexes pavloviens mais les chiens de
garde du parlement que nous sommes
veille pourtant sur la nation avec un
esprit de justice fiscale et sociale
vous même monsieur le ministre attaché à
taxer les gaffes a déclaré en décembre
2018 il n'y a pas de succès économique
sans justice sociale alors nous
proposons que l'état joue son rôle de
régulateur en atténuant les effets des
crises auprès de tous par ailleurs ce
réflexe pavlovien le gouvernement ne
l'at il pas eu en 2020 lorsqu'il a
décidé d'une taxe de solidarité
exceptionnel sur les primes des
organismes complémentaires de santé afin
je cite de compenser les profits générés
par les mutuelles pendant la crise
sanitaire y at il eu débat sur
l'opportunité non c'était pure justice
sociale mettre en place un prélèvement
exceptionnel parce qu'il y avait un
enrichissement exceptionnelles liées à
la crise qu vide était juste nous
voulons la même chose concernant les
sociétés qui voient leurs profits bondir
à l'occasion d'une nouvelle crise
nos voisins le fond l'italie l'espagne
la roumanie la grèce et même le royaume
uni les allemands ne devrait pas tarder
nous avons accepté de baisser l'impôt
sur les sociétés nous pensons juste de
prélever une contribution exceptionnelle
parce que la situation est
exceptionnelle le président de la
république disait il y a quelques mois
pour moi la justice sociale c'est de
prévenir les aigus les inégalités eh
bien nous y sommes nous proposons par
ailleurs le report d'un an de la
suppression de la contribution
audiovisuelle publique parce que le
sujet mérite concertation et que cela
n'a pas eu lieu bien sûr le mécanisme de
la crp est obsolète bien sûr il s'agit
d'une promesse du président de la
république c'est pourquoi nous ne nous
opposerons pas à sa suppression mais
pour une fois prenons le temps de penser
à tout et à tous pour permettre de
mettre en place un dispositif
satisfaisant le monde de la culture au
passage nous économisons 3,7 milliards
qui ne feront pas de mal aux intérêts de
notre dette enfin dans le droit fil de
votre judicieux bouclier tarifaire
énergétique françoise gatel présidente
de la délégation aux collectivités
proposera une aide pour les communes qui
voient leur facture énergétique
s'envoler sans ressources
supplémentaires ainsi qu hervé maurey le
dispositif voté par l'assemblée
nationale est trop restrictif car les
bases de compensation liée à l'évolution
de l'épargné brute exclure entre autres
communes aux difficultés multiples voici
donc messieurs les ministres chers
collègues la ligne directrice du groupe
union centriste particulièrement
attentives à l' usage que nous allons
faire de la dette publique je vous
remercie
merci
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant aux présidents jean claude
requier pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique social européen pour cinq
minutes vous avez la parole monsieur le
président
je le président monsieur brillant du
sénat mais j'ai ministre monsieur le
président la course des filles à ce
monsieur a entamé sa collègue ce projet
de loi finances rectificatif pour 2022
et peut-être vérité le texte du surcoût
à l'achat comporte en particulier toutes
les arrange budgétaire attendu par nos
compatriotes après le projet de loi que
nous avons examiné la semaine dernière
dans des virées pratiquement complet
nous faisons pas d'illusion la situation
budgétaire de l'état est difficile après
cela de pandémie politique quoi qu'il en
coûte qui a permis de maintenir à flot
notre économie au prix d'un beau
historique de l'endettement nous sommes
désormais confrontés à un retour de
l'inflation
causée à la fois par les effets du
confinement de l'économie par les
multiples difficultés
d'approvisionnement une hausse
historique des prix de transport de
conteneurs à l'échelle internationale
des tensions sur l'importation de
certains produits
et enfin un affaiblissement de l'euro
par rapport au dollar liée aux
conséquences économiques de la guerre
l'ukraine et sanctionnent qui affecte
plus durement les européens que les
amériques
la faiblesse de l'euro renchérit donc
automatiquement le prix des ressources
libellés dans la monnaie américaine
par le pétrole en particulier à cela
s'ajoute une situation politique
nationale complexe depuis quelques
semaines la nation du président de la
république avril dernier une première
depuis l'instauration du quinquennat a
débouché sur un résultat par
oxaliplatine qui permet à certains
groupes d'opposition de se prétendre
devenir les faiseurs de politique au
moment même où notre pays aurait besoin
des décideurs responsable et lucide le
spectacle parfois ubuesques de l'examen
du projet de loi pouvoir d'achat et de
ce père et faire passer nationale en
s'installant à laisser perplexe beaucoup
opposite ouailles un camp par esprit
sérieux de quelques éléments ne va pas
de ce national ce n'est pas ici que le
consulat politique
pour ce qui concerne les mesures de ce
plfr notre groupe continuera de servir
sa liberté de vote
c'est ce qui veut dire qu'un patient
accord tous par exemple sur des mesures
aussi importantes que la suppression de
la contribution à l'audiovisuel public
l'équipe il a adressé à cet impôt
spécifique sommes connus bien qu'à
question du financement soit essentielle
nous veillerons dans les procès veille à
6 et budgétaires à ce qu'ils soient
assurés à la hauteur de ce que les
citadins d'origine pluie de qualité et
relative de la société mais surtout
sonnée l'occasion de débattre de ce que
doit être pour un véritable public les
problèmes de qualité et les rapports
entre indépendance et purisme afin de
renforcer l'attachement des français
alors audiovisuel commun pour le reste
ce texte comporte des mesures techniques
comme la généralisation de la
facturation électronique et transaction
entre assujettis à tva ou encore des
rectifications de l'ecc et en
particulier le décret datant de quelques
7 milliards d'euros adopté au printemps
pas mal en période électorale la
poursuite élargissement nous sommes des
pg e il lui sa difficulté à sortir
concrètement on dit it if quand j'ai
conçu d'abord comme temporaire mais
largement plébiscité par les acteurs
économiques qui souhaiterait que ça
continue a fait un certain nombre de
mesures consistent à renforcer le
soutien d'organismes internationaux à
l'ukraine je salue pont à part la
majoration de l'article 14 la dotation
au titre sécurisé car on connaît les
difficultés rencontrées actuellement par
les collectivités pour traite les
renouvellements des demandes de deux
cartes d'identité et de passeports des
compensations enfin les collectivités
ont été votés assemblée pour sa phase la
revalorisation des pointes des listes
des fonctionnaires et du rsa nous
proposons de l'événement vise à aller
plus loin dans le sens que quand nous
semble pas suffisant de cellules nous
proposera également de territorialiser
davantage certaines règles modifiées
pour ce qui concerne la lutte contre la
hausse du prix des carburants la run et
insertion de la ddr paraphant
regrettable est nécessaire j'étais
religieux de camions sur le président
avant de conclure je n'oublie pas
également la question de la taxation des
supers profits des entreprises nous
attendons beaucoup de ce débat qui aura
lieu dans quelques et les femmes en
conclusion cpr discuter en toute fin de
session n'en finit pas de comporter des
mesures parce qu'il est ici ce qui est
infiniment
comme même comme port des mesures
nécessaires bien que nous puissions par
repousser indéfiniment la question de la
dette l'euro perdait pour sa part les
caméras sont mortes à l'effigié va et en
fonction des modifications qui seront
apportées par le sénat
merci monsieur le programme non non pas
du trimestre et 20 secondes et oui
merci en tout cas pour votre humour le
la parole est maintenant monsieur rémi
féraud pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains pour cinq
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
président du sénat messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances et monsieur le
rapporteur général chers collègues ce
projet de loi de finances rectificative
comme le texte que nous venons de voter
sur le pouvoir d'achat il se définit par
ce qu'il ya dedans les ministres l'ont
rappelé mais aussi et peut-être surtout
parce qu'il ne contient pas
sur le pouvoir d'achat le grand absent
s'était ainsi la revalorisation des
salaires et dans ce plfr le grand absent
c'est la contribution du capital et de
ceux qui le détiennent mais il ya une
nouvelle situation politique qui permet
de vraies avancées au parlement cela a
été le cas à l'assemblée nationale pour
les collectivités locales et face à
l'urgence territoriales nous espérons
bien conserver voire amplifier les
avancées obtenues sur ce point c'est
même le rôle du sénat nous avons aussi
je crois le devoir de faire un pas vers
plus de justice fiscale et donc vers une
participation des grandes entreprises et
des plus fortunés à l'effort du pays
nous ne voulions pas vous décevoir
monsieur le ministre j'ai compris que
nous n'étions d'ailleurs à gauche pas
les seuls à le dire que cela allait bien
au-delà et le gouvernement est
aujourd'hui sur la défensive donc chers
collègues et y ont de l'audace bien sûr
nous pensons indispensable la création
d'un isf climatique dont les recettes
pourraient aller vers des mesures plus
solidaire de transition énergétique des
recettes qui permettrait d'augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat à la hauteur de
l'inflation sans entamer le reste à
vivre des plus modestes comme c'est le
cas avec les mesures trop limité
aujourd'hui et sans toucher au temps de
travail comme le gouvernement s'apprête
à le faire avec le concours de la droite
par ailleurs tout conduit à mettre en
place une taxe exceptionnelle sur les
super profits des grandes sociétés de
l'énergie et des transports
cette mesure elle est tellement légitime
qu'elle s'est invitée jusqu'au sein de
la majorité présidentielle
d'autant que les ressources ne manquent
pas quand on voit les bénéfices records
annoncés notamment par total énergie et
par là c est ma cg m alors messieurs les
ministres renoncer aux discours de
l'impuissance celui qui se contente de
faire appel au bon vouloir des
entreprises car ce faux-semblant ne
trompe plus personne
regardez l'état de nos services publics
et l'explosion des inégalités
rappelez-vous la crise des gilet jaune
elle n'est pas si ancien vous noterez
que nos propositions elles sont très
bénéfique pour les finances publiques
puisque elle dégage au total près de 25
milliards d'euros de recettes et je
crois qu'il est temps d'ajouter ô
combien ça coûte le combien ça rapporte
sinon en s'obstinant dans son refus le
gouvernement démontrerait qu'il n'est
pas celui de la maîtrise des finances
publiques mais aussi celui du déficit
regardez ce qui se passe chez nos
voisins européens un effort bien plus
conséquent sur les transports publics
comme en allemagne ou en espagne qui
devrait nous servir d'exemple et dans
ces deux pays
comme en italie et au royaume uni une
taxe sur les super-profits voit le jour
et cela n'a rien à voir avec le niveau
de fiscalité général sur nos entreprises
alors vous voyez c'est nécessaire et
c'est possible et ne ratons pas cette
occasion enfin et je conclurai par là ce
qui manque au texte messieurs les
ministres à votre texte cet outil de
préservation de notre démocratie car
fragiliser le service public de
l'audiovisuel
aujourd'hui c'est une erreur et même une
faute c'est pourquoi nous proposerons
une nouvelle forme de redevance
audiovisuelle en revenant sur sa
suppression pure et simple présenté à
tort comme une mesure de pouvoir d'achat
c'est un enjeu essentiel pour notre
démocratie
la qualité l'indépendance de
l'information
la création culturelle le système que
nous proposons il est plus juste et
progressif que l'actuel redevance mais
surtout contrairement aux vôtres qui
relève de l'improvisation et qui avec la
tva reprend d'une main ce qu'il a fait
semblant de donner de l'autre notre
nouvelle contribution elle elle préserve
vraiment le financement le financement
spécifique et l'indépendance de
l'audiovisuel public ces dernières
semaines des voix se sont levés de plus
en plus nombreuses pour dire que sa
suppression était une fausse bonne idée
alors quand il s'agit de taxer les
superprofits il serait urgent d'attendre
hélas pour supprimer un outil
démocratique précieux il n'y aurait pas
une minute à perdre soyons sérieux et
chers collègues au delà même des
clivages partisans prenons nos
responsabilités
je vous remercie
merci
la parole est maintenant à monsieur teva
rofritsch pour le groupe rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendants pour six minutes vous avez
la parole cher collègue
monsieur le président monsieur président
du sénat sur la porter général messieurs
les ministres chers collègues ce que
président la commission des finances
le texte que nous examinons cet après
midi a fait l'objet d'importants
compromis tout au long de sa discussion
à l'assemblée nationale
ait été adopté il ya plus six jours un
très large majorité par nos collègues
députés je vous parle d'une très large
majorité car la majorité absolue des
votants était dépassés de 73 voix c'est
une victoire considérable pour la
démocratie compte tenu de la nouvelle
configuration politique la députée
véronique louwagie soulignait notamment
le souhait du groupe l'est républicain
d'incarner une opposition raisonnable
je ne peux qu'espérer que cet état
d'esprit préside également à nos débats
je ne doute pas mes chers collègues que
le sénat sera fait faire preuve de
responsabilité et trouver les mêmes voie
constructive que nos collègues députés
qu'il remplira avec sagesse et nouvelle
fois son rôle de chambre de compromis
c'est une responsabilité d'autant plus
grande que ce collectif budgétaire est
le corollaire indispensable du texte de
pouvoir d'achat que nous avons adopté
vendredi dernier à la tombée de la nuit
et je crois profondément que nous serons
trouver une issue raisonnable en cmp sur
le texte pour achat dès ce soir comme
nous le ferons cours de la semaine ce
budget rectificatif qui nous est soumis
cet esprit compromis le gouvernement en
a fait la preuve puisque jusqu'à la fin
de l'examen en séance publique à la
faveur à la faveur pardon dans
l'amendement proposant d'aider les
ménages se chauffant au fioul vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le ministre ce
sont 230 millions d'euros qui d'ici
l'hiver aideront nos concitoyens a passé
le retour du froid sans subir de plein
fouet la flambée des coûts de l'énergie
cet esprit de compromis le groupe r des
pays en prendre également sa part en
rejoignant l'initiative de notre
rapporteur général de pérenniser le
nouveau plafond d'exonération des heures
supplémentaires je suis rapporteur
général votre amendement nous paraît une
aide bienvenue à l'emploi qu'on la
prospérité notre économie et la
soutenabilité nos finances publiques
repose en grande partie sur le dynamisme
du marché du travail et la productivité
de nos entreprises
cet esprit compromis enfin nous l'avons
vu à l'oeuvre sur un sujet qui nous
préoccupe tout particulièrement ici au
sénat je veux bien entendu parler des
collectivités locales nous n'oublions
pas tout ce qui a été fait depuis 2010
est avec une capacité d'autofinancement
brute qui s'est envolé de 23 2% sur le
quinquennat une trésorerie en hausse de
36 4% et les dépenses réelles
d'investissement qui ont augmenté de 14
9% tout cela grâce aux mesures inédites
de soutien et de compensation dynamique
que nous avons mis en place je n'oublie
pas également le dynamisme d'un grand
nombre de recettes fiscales des
collectivités les démons la tva d'une
large part leur revient la taxe foncière
et j'en passe mais en particulier pour
le bloc communal il demeure
d'importantes disparités et certains de
nos communes ont besoin d'un soutien
exceptionnel c'est pour cela qu'un
compromis a été trouvé autour du
rapporteur général jean-rené cazeneuve
dont je salue le travail
il a permis de mettre en place une
dotation exceptionnelle pour les
communes les plus touchées par la hausse
des coûts nous avons là encore des
propositions à faire valoir pour
améliorer le dispositif
mais je ne doute pas que nous trouverons
tous ensemble et avec le gouvernement
les mesures adaptées pour protéger nos
communes menacées par l'envol du coût de
l'énergie
nos collègues ultramarins du groupe r
des pays sont nombreux à saluer les
avancées obtenues en première lecture
notamment l' enveloppe exceptionnelle
des d'alimentaire ouverte pour lutter
contre la vie chère
je sais monsieur le ministre comme vous
l'avez fait auparavant vous regarderez
avec des ambiances notre amendement qui
prévoit de l'élargir aux collectivités
d'outre-mer c'est un enjeu de solidarité
mais aussi d' égalité justice pour la
polynésie française la nouvelle
calédonie et l'ensemble des
collectivités d'outre-mer je sais que
vous y êtes sensibles monsieur le
ministre je n'oublie pas votre action
suite à m'associer de sollicitations
dernier projet de loi de finances pour
aider air tahiti nui alors en grande
difficulté merci monsieur le maire
j'ajoute enfin que je partage avec nos
amis ultramarins et ma collègue
finistérienne nadège avait le
soulagement que constitue la
prolongation de l'aide aux carburants
pour les pêcheurs annoncé vendredi
dernier par le secrétaire d'état en
charge de la mer c'est une mesure juste
qui viendra en aide à un secteur
fortement touché par le retour de
l'inflation
alors oui mes chers collègues comme le
disait notre collègue député mathieu le
faire je suis heureux que nous puissions
discuter d'un texte qui revalorise
revalorisera les pensions de 60 euros
par mois qui fera en sorte que les prix
du gaz électricité des français
n'augmenteront pas de 4% à 2 35% comme
cela aurait été le cas si nous n'avions
rien fait
car notre pays connaît malgré son niveau
l'inflation la plus modérée d'europe une
croissance dynamique comme certains nos
voisins enregistre quand certains de nos
voisins enregistre une baisse au
deuxième trimestre un taux de chômage
d'historiquement bas à 16,3 pour cent ce
sont les fruits de la constance de notre
politique économique et des mesures
pouvoir d'achat engagé dès le début de
la crise
chers collègues vous connaissez
l'expression il ne faut pas changer de
cheval au milieu du gué je pense en
particulier aux débats que nous aurons
sur la taxe exceptionnelle que certains
veulent mettre en place il en va de la
confiance dans notre politique
économique de la clarté de la cohérence
de notre modèle fiscal le gouvernement a
demandé aux entreprises des engagements
nous saurons être au rendez vous des
résultats est sanctionné ce qui devra
l'être quand le temps sera venu de
demander des comptes mais ne pénalisons
pas la reprise alors que notre économie
sort tout juste de la crise
avec ce texte sont 20 milliards d'euros
qui seront rendus à nos concitoyens
c'est un grand moment de démocratie
parlementaire et ce sera de nos votes
que nous devrons répondre quand il
faudra dire si oui ou non nous avons été
à la hauteur des enjeux je vous remercie
votre attention
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame vanina paolig agen
pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires pour cinq
minutes
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
tous les marins le savent la navigation
est un art de l'anticipation le
capitaine d'un grand paquebot doit ainsi
attendre 30 minutes entre son coup de
barre et son effet sur la trajectoire du
navire pour redresser les finances
publiques
d'inertie est bien évidemment plus
longue c'est en année sinon en décennies
que se résorbe les déficits chroniques
et les dettes abyssales
alors si ce budget marque la fin du quoi
qu'il en coûte ces effets ne se feront
que malheureusement pas sentir avant des
années monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui la situation de nos finances
publiques est bien évidemment tout le
monde le sait alarmante encore une fois
elle l'est par les décisions que nous
avons prises collectivement notamment au
plus fort de la crise pour préserver nos
emplois sauvegardés nos entreprises
protéger nos concitoyens notre dette
publique est supérieure de plus de 15
points de pib à celle de 2010 9 niveaux
qui nous préoccupait déjà à juste titre
pourtant nous vivons sous anesthésie
générale
le contexte des taux négatifs quand des
cette dynamique d'endettement finalement
artificiellement à c'est indolore la
charge de la dette ne sais c'est de
diminuer alors que la dette elle-même ne
cessé d'augmenter désormais la charge
augmente dangereusement et nous obligent
à cibler nos mesures à prioriser nos
urgences en l'occurrence l'urgence et
sociales l'inflation qui frappe tout le
pays touche plus durement les plus
fragiles le taux moyen qu'il soit 5 ou
6% qu'en fait correspondre à une
augmentation du coût de la vie de près
de 10% c'est toute l'injustice de la
situation on souffre davantage de la
hausse des prix de l'énergie de
l'alimentation quand on vit dans les
territoires ruraux avec des revenus
modestes
c'est pourquoi le ciblage des mesures
sur le coût de l'énergie et ce pour les
plus modestes fait sens
l'hiver arrivera vite si l'inflation
persistent elles restent pour le moment
inférieur à la moyenne européenne
c'est en partie grâce à la réactivité du
gouvernement en partie grâce à notre
moindre dépendance au gaz russe mais il
n'est pas impossible qu'elle nous fera
part effet retard il faut donc être
clair
le budget rectificatif que nous allons
examiner n'est pas un budget de
rétablissement des comptes publics il
répond à l'urgence de la situation avec
un souci d'efficience que chacun
appréciera
nous aurons prochainement l'occasion de
discuter des grandes orientations
budgétaires nous devons les prendre en
responsabilité en gardant à l'esprit le
fait que le spectre de la récession
guette notre pays comme la zone euro
pour l'heure j'espère que nous saurons
créer des consensus pour protéger le
pouvoir d'achat des français
singulièrement celui des plus modestes
dans les territoires ruraux le projet
doit pouvoir d'achat a montré que nous
en étions tous ensemble capable
j'identifie pour ma part trois sujets
épineux au fond je crois que nous sommes
plutôt d'accord mais devons-nous
répondre à une question de justice
fiscale
qui doit supporter le coût des mesures
que nous voterons le premier sujet c'est
bien sûr la contribution à l'audiovisuel
public sa suppression ne fait pas débat
la question a été tranchée à la
présidentielle les français ont choisi
au premier tour deux candidats qui
supprimait cet acte elle n'a plus de
sens à une époque où l'audiovisuel passe
essentiellement par internet mais
comment garantir le financement notre
audiovisuel public en supprimant une
taxe injuste pour les français est
inadapté à la réalité économique du
secteur la solution retenue par le
gouvernement du fléchage d'une traction
de teva ne me paraît pas optimal car ce
mode de financement n'est ni stable ni
pérenne son seul mérite est d'être
opérante à court terme pour ma part je
pense qu'il faut faire contribuer
davantage les géants du numérique qui
ont changé la donne et je vous
proposerai un amendement en ce sens qui
pourrait amorcer une nouvelle voie de
réflexion le deuxième sujet épineux
c'est la taxation des supers profits
c'est sans doute un réflexe bien
français que de répondre à une crise par
une taxe pourtant d'autres pays dont le
royaume uni et l'espagne se sont
empressés de copier notre grand remède
nationale
mais même si la tentation est grande
notre réponse doit à mon sens plutôt
être le fruit d'une réflexion objective
multisectorielle le cas échéant enfin
sur le dernier sujet épineux c'est la
compensation par l'état des surcoûts
supportés par les collectivités
le débat a déjà eu à l'assemblée nous
l'aurons ici car nous nous portons tous
une attention particulière aux
collectivités locales et nous
proposerons avec les indépendants des
amendements en ce sens sur l'impact de
la revalorisation du point d'indicé pour
la fonction publique territoriale
je veux être clair la compensation par
l'état ne crée pas de dépenses publiques
supplémentaires
il ya bien une hausse de dépenses mais
elle a été décidée par décret il faut
maintenant dire qui paiera je crois que
l'effort doit être partagé entre les
collectivités et l'état qui a déjà
beaucoup fait mais soyons lucides en
matière de finances publiques c'est
toujours le contribuable qui paie in
fine et et en matière de vote au sein du
groupe les indépendants république et
territoires c'est toujours le votant qui
choisit je vous remercie
merci de cette conclusion et je donne
maintenant la parole à monsieur vincent
segouin pour le groupe l'est républicain
pour neuf minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues ce premier budget du second
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron s'inscrit
dans un contexte particulier tant sur le
fond que sur la forme sur le fond nous
vivons une période de hausse de
l'inflation sans précédent depuis des
années 80 qui met à mal notre économie
est aussi le pouvoir d'achat des
français
la crise actuelle fait suite à la guerre
en ukraine à la crise énergétique mais
aussi à la crise économique sans
précédent que nous avons traversée suite
aux périodes de confinement liés à la
pandémie sur la forme maintenant ce
collectif budgétaire va avancer dans un
contexte politique inédit avec une
majorité relative à l'assemblée
nationale ce qui permet au président la
république de découvrir en bout de cinq
ans ce qu'est la démocratie
représentative
le parlement revient au centre du jeu
place qui n'ont jamais dû quitter et
nous nous en félicitons
le contexte est donc singulier et appel
pour ces deux raisons de fond et de
forme à la plus grande responsabilité de
notre part notre groupe au sénat n'a
cessé depuis cinquante-deux mener une
opposition constructive au gouvernement
mus par le seul sens de l'intérêt de la
france
dans le nouvel équilibre politique
actuelle notre responsabilité dans
l'opposition est de convaincre le
gouvernement du bien fondé de nos
propositions
notre pays ne peut plus se permettre de
perdre encore cinq ans sinon il sera
sans doute trop tard le contexte
d'argent magique et d'argent soit disant
gratuit a également changé
le retour de l'inflation contraint les
banques centrales et des institutions
monétaires à réagir la semaine dernière
la réserve fédérale américaine a décidé
une nouvelle hausse du taux exceptionnel
de 0,75 comme le mois dernier qui
constituait déjà un record depuis 1994
au total la fed à relever son taux
directeur de 2 25% depuis le début de
l'année la semaine dernière également la
bce pour la première fois depuis onze
ans a relevé son principal taux de 0 25%
cela conduit un relèvement des taux
d'intérêt les taux des us à 10 ans ont
dépassé les 3% en mai et les eaux à tes
dix ans qui nous concerne ont largement
dépassé les 2% en juin je rappelle juste
qu'ils étaient encore négatif au mois de
décembre
aujourd'hui nous sommes entre 1,50 et
1,60 pour cent mais je rappelle que
selon l'agencé france trésor 1 point de
taux d'intérêt ces 2,5 milliards d'euros
de charges de la dette en plus et selon
la banque de france 40 milliards d'euros
par an au bout de dix ans à cela
s'ajoute l'effet de la hausse de
l'inflation sur laquelle 10% de notre
dette est indexé
là encore un point d'inflexion en plus
c'est encore 2,5 milliards d'euros de
charges de la dette en plus l'intérêt de
la dette était depuis de nombreuses
années le troisième poste de défense de
l'état
après l'enseignement scolaire à la
défense elle est passée de 38 milliards
51 milliards en un an est bien aussi
dépassé le budget de la défense est ce
un rythme elle pourrait devenir dans peu
de temps le premier budget de l'état
imaginez tout ce que nous pourrions
faire avec ces 50 milliards d'euros pour
le pouvoir d'achat des français et la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
le gouverneur de la banque de france
vient de mettre en garde le gouvernement
qu'il serait je le cite illusoire de
penser que notre dette est encore sans
couilles sans limite il juge que la
france ne peut pas se permettre de
transmettre un tel poids de dettes à sa
jeunesse
le haut conseil des finances publiques
estime pour sa part que notre
endettement est un point de
vulnérabilité
il ya un mois monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances semblait
découvrir le problème en estimant que
nous avons atteint le cot dalet dallaire
sur nos finances publiques alors même
que quatre mois plus tôt il déclarait je
le cite contrairement à ce que disent
tous les cassandre pour la campagne
électorale l'économie française se porte
très bien
ce n'est pourtant pas faute durant le
précédent quinquennat de n'avoir cessé
au sénat de mettre en garde le
gouvernement contre une remontée des
taux d'intérêt et nous avons insisté sur
la nécessité de réaliser des économies
et des réformes structurel
comment en sommes-nous arrivés là des
différentes crise n'explique pas tout
autant il était nécessaire de soutenir
et relancer notre économie durant cette
période et nous l'avons approuvé
autant le quoi qu'il en coûte a été
général et a couvert les dépenses qu'ils
n'avaient rien à voir avec la crise
hausse des dépenses absence d'économies
la diminution de 50 mille postes dans la
fonction publique d'état a été
abandonnée lors du précédent quinquennat
comme la réforme des retraites alors
qu'il s'agissait de promesses de notre
du candidat macron il nous promet que la
réforme des retraites se fera lors de ce
nouveau quinquennat devons-nous le
croire
la réforme a déjà été repoussée d'un an
à l'été 2000 23 alors que nous savons
très bien que les réformes des plus
difficiles doivent être engagées dès la
première année c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous proposerons dans ce
collectif budgétaire que la mise en
place de la carte vitale biométrique se
fasse sans attendre nous n'avons pas
besoin d'une mission parlementaire
supplémentaire pour savoir que cela
engendrera des économies des économies
sont nécessaires pour financer les
dépenses celles ci ne doivent pas être
financée par le surcroît des recettes
comme l'a très bien dit la cour des
comptes les recettes imprévu doivent
aller au désendettement du pays or
toutes les dépenses de ce plfr sont
financés par la hausse des recettes qui
est d'ailleurs en grande partie due à la
hausse de l'inflation
ce n'est pas sain surtout quand vos
prévisions de recettes sont basées sur
une croissance que nous jugeons comme le
haut conseil des finances publiques
surestimer la croissance française pâti
en réalité d'une vraie pénurie de main
d'oeuvre dans de nombreux secteurs le
taux de chômage en france de mère bien
plus élevé que la moyenne européenne
selon les derniers chiffes en mai 2021
nous sommes à 7,2 pour cent de vie 8% en
allemagne et les états unis à 3,6 c'est
la raison pour laquelle il faut
permettre d'aider de manière durable les
entreprises à maintenir un niveau
d'activité suffisant face aux problèmes
de recrutement auxquels elles sont
confrontées chaque jour c'est notamment
dans ce sens que nous proposons de
pérenniser la oz défiscalisation et de
la désocialisation des heures
supplémentaires le travail doit être
encouragée valoriser c'est une valeur
essentielle à nos yeux dans le même
esprit nous proposons que le rachat des
rtt soit pérennisée mais également que
la prime de rentrée cible les
travailleurs pauvres plutôt que les
bénéficiaires des minima sociaux qu'ils
ne travaillent pas ce sont aussi des
mesures de pouvoir d'achat car celui-ci
se gagne avant tout par le travail nous
nous félicitons que d'importantes
mesures proposées par les députés des
républicains était adoptée à l'assemblée
nationale sur le travail j'ai cité le
rachat possible des rtt la hausse de
5000 à 7000 500 euros du plafond de
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
même si à titre personnel je serais
plutôt pour un déplafonnement total mais
nous y reviendrons pour faire face à la
crise énergétique qui impacte fortement
le pouvoir d'achat de beaucoup de
français notamment dans les territoires
ruraux nous nous félicitons de l'accord
trouvé de remise de 30 centimes du prix
à la pompe mais aussi de l'adoption de
nos mesures de soutien des petites
stations service situées dans les zones
rurales et des particuliers qui se
chauffe au fuel qui avaient été les
grands oubliés du dispositif initial
le filet de sécurité pour les
collectivités territoriales adoptée de
manière concertée par les députés pour
faire face à la hausse de leur facture
énergétique et du coup du point dadis
est un premier pas nous proposerons de
l'améliorer notre groupe vous annonce
d'ores et déjà monsieur le ministre que
nous demanderons la taxation de dgf dans
le pnf de 2023 enfin le vote final des
républicains de ce budget rectificatif
dépendra de lui coûte que vous voudrez
bien nous accorder des propositions que
vous accepterez il en va de l'intérêt de
notre pays je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur daniel brouillé pour
le groupe écologie solidarité territoire
pour cinq minutes
c'est le président monsieur le président
du sénat messieurs monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur général chez le
président de la commission des finances
cher collègue monsieur le ministre
vous décrivez le contexte avec beaucoup
de gravité
j'ajouterai d'ailleurs car vous
n'évoquez que timidement à la guerre en
ukraine à la dette à l'inflation la
grave crise climatique et son corollaire
l'exigence de la transition écologique
faire le point est indispensable mais ce
serait inutile si ensuite nous ne
choisissions pas le bon cap et quel est
votre cap monsieur le ministre sur la
dette 20 milliards supplémentaires
portent le déficit public annuel à 177
milliards
justifiant le terme de côte d' alerte
mais si cette côte d'alerté est atteinte
pourquoi renforcer ce déficit de plus de
3 milliards en supprimant la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public pour
le pouvoir d'achat des français taxer
les plateformes bloquer les prix des
loyers et là vous allez gérer le coût de
la vie de nos concitoyens surtout les
bandes notre assemblée des voix
demandent que l'enjeu de l'audiovisuel
public ne soit pas traitée au détour
d'une décision mal préparés d'un article
du plfr dans une société de défiance et
de fait qu news les questions
d'indépendance et de fiabilité de
l'information sont essentielles comme
celle du soutien à la création et aux
artistes
d'innovation d'éducation qui sont
portées avec exigence par notre service
public de l'audiovisuel
ces questions ne se règle pas sans
prendre le temps d'un débat avec la
représentation nationale avec les
professionnels et les usagers
changer de cap monsieur le ministre
plutôt que de supprimer rapidement 7 c
ap pour la dette encore vous nous
expliquer qu'il ne faut pas taxer les
superprofits taxer les superprofits de
mots que vous récusez mais d'autres pays
le font en europe 18 milliards pour
total et un geste à 500 millions n'est
ce pas le retour de la charité plutôt
que le choix de la solidarité et de
l'impôt votre cap c'est moins d'impôts
pour les grandes sociétés et des revenus
désocialisés et défiscalisées pour les
salariés mais comme le disait henry
morgann tôt les impôts sont le prix à
payer pour une société civilisée
convaincu de cela nous proposerons de
taxer les super profits et plus
particulièrement les profiteurs de crise
qui nourrissent d'ailleurs l'inflation
en augmentant leurs marges nous
proposons aussi de créer un isf
climatique structurée sur solidarité
sociale et transition écologique il
permet la contribution des plus fortunés
et ils en seront heureux dans les bilans
carbone sont par ailleurs les plus
désastreux il n'est pas socialement
acceptable de demander des efforts à nos
concitoyens modeste au nom de la gravité
de la situation est de constater que le
cac40 distribuer 50 7 milliards de
dividendes record européen ou que les
500 plus riches d'entre nous voient leur
patrimoine dépassé les 1000 milliards
ces chiffres sont vertigineux pour nos
concitoyens rien ne justifie qu'un
éleveur laitier un maraîcher qui fournit
une grande enseigne gagnent en moyenne
500 fois moins que le pdg de cette
enseigne ou que dans les entreprises du
cac 40 des salaires varient de 1 à 300
entre patrons et salariés rien ne
justifie que la finance soit moins taxé
que le travail personne ne vaut 300 fois
plus qu'un autre et comme le disait le
président macron notre pays tient tout
entier sur ces hommes et ces femmes que
nos économies reconnaissent et rémunère
si mal eh bien il est temps de mieux les
reconnaître et de mieux les rémunérer
nous vous faisons une proposition simple
augmenter le smic à 15 cents euros
soutenir les pme tpe par un fonds de
solidarité
revalorisation revalorisé de 10% le
point d'indicé des fonctionnaires et
porter toutes les retraites et
prestation service social inscrits à ce
plfr au niveau réel de l'inflation un
mot sur la guerre qui frappe le peuple
ukrainien pour lequel nous ré exprimons
notre solidarité et nous approuverons
les mesures du plfr
nous mesurons les risques
d'approvisionnement et nous mesurons
surtout la profondeur de la crise
énergétique
c'est le prix de notre inaction
climatique passe et cela appelle certes
des mesures d'urgence mais surtout
d'engager le chemin de l'autonomie
énergétique
mais là encore quel est le cap remplacer
la dépendance au gaz russe par une
dépendance au gaz de schiste américain
ce n'est pas acceptable seul cap
possible est celui de la sobriété allié
au développement rapide des
renouvelables nous proposons 10
milliards dans l'isolation thermique des
logements plutôt que les 400 millions de
ce plfr pas seulement pour changer une
chaudière mais pour une véritable
rénovation thermique des habitats des
locaux d'activités des équipements
publics enfin sur le bouclier tarifaire
il doit être étendue aux collectivités
dont certaines sont contraintes de
fermer leur piscine quant aux citoyens
les 30 centimes de baisse uniforme sur
les carburants vont aggraver le déficit
public en a dedans les propriétaires de
suv à partir en week-end les week-ends à
saint jean cap ferrat avec subvention de
l'état qui peut défendre ça cette aide
doit être réservé à nos concitoyens qui
n'ont pas d'autre choix que la voiture
pour se rendre au travail lorsque les
forêts brûlent les glaciers
disparaissent les départements sont en
sécheresse et en restriction d'accès à
l'eau l'agriculture mise à mal il faut
un autre cap celui 1,4 eu que pour nos
pays ses habitants et la planète nous
ferons des propositions en ce sens
merci
la parole est maintenant monsieur
jean-marie misons pour le groupe union
centriste pour 3 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues
le budget rectificatif dont nous allons
débattre aujourd'hui et demain est le
premier de l'année 2022 il poursuit dans
un environnement inflationniste qui se
durcit l'objectif de redonner du pouvoir
d'achat aux français c'est là elle nous
invite un objectif noble que tout le
monde ne peut que partager sur ses bancs
ceux qui semblent consensuelles
également mais qui ne devrait pas l'être
c'est le moyen de remplir cet objectif
en l'occurrence le recours encore et
toujours à la dépense publique
héritée de la pandémie de qu'ovide le
syndrome de l'argent magic a
malheureusement anesthésier les réflexes
de sagesse budgétaire qui aurait prévalu
en d'autres temps par rapport à la loi
de finances initiale les dépenses
pilotable augmente de plus de 18
milliards d'euros c'est colossal
parant au plus pressé nous avons
collectivement abandonner toute
réflexion de long terme quant aux
conditions d'une prospérité retrouvée
car le pouvoir d'achat ne se décrète pas
il n'est il vient non pas de l'état mais
des gars de productivité de l'économie
la fuite en avant de la dépense publique
a ceci de mortifère que ses conséquences
néfastes et diffuse ne sont visibles que
sur le temps long
dans son essai ce qu'on voit et ce qu'on
ne voit pas le célèbre économiste
français frédéric bastiat distingué en
ces termes le mauvais économistes d'ubs
ont
l'un
s'en tient à l'effet visible
l'autre tient compte et de l'effet que
le convoi et de ce qu'il faut prévoir
nous lie suis que le mauvais économistes
poursuite un petit bien actuel qui sera
suivie d'un grand mal à venir tandis que
le vrai que vrai économistes poursuite à
grand bien à venir
au risque d'un petit mâle actuelle en
laissant filer la dépense publique et
les déficits et donc en fait compte
l'endettement du pays je crains mes
chers collègues que nous sacrifions ce
grand bien à venir dont parlait bastien
quand les comptes sont dans le rouge il
faut à tout le moins dépensé
efficacement ses cannes ce qu'ils
disaient quand on veut sortir du trou il
faut commencer par cesser de creuser
c'est à dire
cibler en priorité les ménages les plus
vulnérables et les territoires les plus
affectés par l'inflation en particulier
les communes rurales et les territoires
ultramarins or ce n'est pas la direction
prise par ce budget rectificatif qui
privilégie les mesures générales et à
différencier aux mesures temporaires et
ciblées le groupe union centriste et ma
collègue sylvie vermeillet les abris a
brièvement exposé tout à leur fera cette
fois ci encore un an un certain nombre
de propositions
allons alliant sobriété budgétaire
efficacité économique et justice sociale
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur
thierry cozic pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains pour 4
minutes
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues disons le
franchement une fois n'est pas coutume
ce projet de loi de finances
rectificatif s'inscrit dans la droite
ligne de la droite
à vous écouter je peine à comprendre le
procédé schizophrénie qui consiste à
taxer d'irresponsables tout
contradicteur qui prône une meilleure
répartition de la richesse par la
dépense publique
car monsieur le ministre vous êtes tous
sauf un bon gestionnaire vous êtes le
rappelle le ministre qui a le plus
dépensé ces dernières années bien sûr je
ne parle pas ici des aides légitimes qui
ont été mises en place pour soutenir le
pays durant la crise qu vide je parle
plutôt du creusement du déficit que vous
opérez à l'aide de vos nombreuses et
systémique baisses d'impôts de
production ou d'impôt sur les sociétés
je ne dis rien de bien original
finalement je ne fais que reprendre les
propos de la cour des comptes qui impute
une partie de la dégradation des comptes
publics à des mesures nouvelles qui ont
réduit les prélèvements obligatoires en
effet sur le quinquennat précédent le
taux de l'impôt sur les sociétés est
passé de 33 3 25% soit 15 milliards
d'euros par an
dans le même temps une partie des impôts
de production pour 10 milliards d'euros
par an a été réduite la suppression
annoncée de la cvae effective dès 2023
coûtera aux finances publiques
8 milliards d'euros s'ajoutant ainsi à
la longue liste des aides venant
conforter la politique de l'offre
vous organisez volontairement
l'attrition des finances publiques et
incidemment vous creusez inutilement le
déficit public et la dette
ces 12 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
qui sont inscrits dans ce budget pour
faire face aux intérêts d'emprunt c'est
colossal
vous avez affirmé monsieur le ministre
ne pas vouloir d'un compromis qui
s'achète à coups de milliards d'un
compromis qui se financent au détriment
de nos finances publiques
il semblerait qu'avec ces baisses
d'impôts de production vous ayez forger
un compromis qui coûte pourtant très
cher à nos finances publiques
le fait que ces impôts profite aux
grandes entreprises
faudrait-il votre cécité
je n'ose le croire même si votre nom
cement à taxer les superprofits certains
profiteurs de guerre me laisse à penser
qu'en matière de compromis vous semblez
souvent en faire toujours au profit des
mêmes car tout comme le projet de loi
portant mesures d'urgence pour la
protection du pouvoir d'achat
ce premier plfr s'inscrit dans la
continuité de la politique économique
menée ces dernières années une politique
basée sur l'offre et qui profite aux
mêmes
ce plfr est le corollaire de votre noble
qui consiste à refuser de prendre toutes
mesures de nature à augmenter les
salaires
la semaine dernière lors de l'examen du
pgi est le pouvoir d'achat est alors que
je proposais avec mais avec mon groupe à
grenelle des salaires afin d' aborde
d'aborder un partage de la richesse plus
égale dans ce pays vous avez balayé d'un
revers de la main cette possibilité or
c'est précisément parce que vous refusez
toucher au salaire qu'il vous faut faire
du bricolage fiscal afin de poser
quelques rustines ça et la prime petit
chèque baisses d'impôts en cela le
triplement de la prime du plafond de la
prime bac rond 2000 à 3000 euros pour la
grande majorité des entreprises voire
6000 euros dans certains cas ne trahit
que trop bien cette fuite en avant vous
avez engagé
en conclusion ce le ministre ce plfr et
la transcription fiscale des mesures
prises dans le pouvoir dans le pgl
pouvoir d'achat or ce dernier est
lacunaire et porte la lourde marque des
dogmes qui animent la vie nos finances
publiques depuis cinq ans sans
changement de cap claires et radicales
nous serons condamnés à traiter ce plfr
pour ce qu'il est à savoir une loi de
finances inégalitaire qui fait peser sur
les mêmes l'obligation d'assainissement
des comptes publics
vous nous parliez de la nouvelle méthode
empreinte de compromis nous espérons que
de compromis il sera question durant
l'examen de ce texte afin de remettre
plus de justice fiscale dans ce pays
merci chers collègues
la parole est aux dernières orateurs
inscrits monsieur jean raymond hugonnet
pour le groupe l'est républicain pour
cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président la
commission des finances le rapporteur
général chers collègues il ya quelques
semaines la commission de la culture et
la commission des finances ont adopté
conjointement ici au sénat un rapport
portant sur le financement de
l'audiovisuel public
ce rapport préparé avec mon collègue
roger karoutchi a établi un état des
lieux qui tient en trois points
premier constat la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public cap qui lie le
financement de l'audiovisuel public à la
possession d'un poste de télévision est
devenue un prélèvement insuffisant
injuste et fragile de plus en plus de
personnes renoncent à posséder un
téléviseur et consomment des programmes
publics sur d'autres supports par
ailleurs la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation funeste rançon recouvrement
très coûteux le remplacement de la cape
est donc inévitable il devait avoir lieu
au cours du précédent quinquennat cela
n'a malheureusement pas été le cas
deuxième constat on ne peut traiter
séparément le financement de
l'audiovisuel public de son organisation
et de ses missions quels moyens pour
quels mission quelles spécificités pour
l'audiovisuel public traiter la seule
question du remplacement de la cap sans
même ouvrir le débat sur la place de la
publicité sur le service public par
exemple illustre une absence de vision
et d'ambition pour ce secteur
l'échec de la réforme de l'audiovisuel
public en 2020 a fait perdre beaucoup de
temps et rend d'autant plus impérative
une réforme
troisième constat face à l'émergence des
grandes plateformes et aux puissants
groupement de média privé réunissant
télévisions et radios il est urgent pour
l'audiovisuel public de concevoir une
stratégie numérique commune ce qui passe
par un regroupement des moyens
l'échec de saltos et les performances
limitées des rapprochements entre france
télévisions et radio france ont mises en
évidence la faiblesse de la stratégie
des petits pas en inscrivant à la hâte
la réforme de la cap dans ce projet de
loi de finances rectificative et en
changeant complètement le dispositif à
l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement
n'a pas tiré toutes les conséquences du
rapport sénatorial
on ne peut aborder la question de la
cape sous le seul angle du pouvoir
d'achat et si nous avons avec roger
karoutchi pris acte de la volonté du
président de la république de supprimer
cet impôt à maints égards suranné nous
avons aussi mis en évidence la nécessité
de prévoir des garanties sérieuses
concernant le financement de
l'audiovisuel public
l'enjeu est moins selon nous de prévenir
d'hypothétiques régulation infra annuel
que de définir de véritables
perspectives pluriannuelles au service
d'une stratégie
je rappelle que si le précédent
quinquennat a été marqué par l'échec de
la réforme de l'audiovisuel public et un
déficit de vision on ne peut que donner
acte aux gouvernements d'avoir respecter
la trajectoire budgétaire quadrillé nal
et même au delà si l'on tient compte des
financements apportés pour financer les
plans de départ les travaux de la maison
de la radio et de la musique ainsi que
les coûts liés à la crise sanitaire
la question est donc moins de savoir
s'il faut financer l'audiovisuel public
par des dotations budgétaires ou une
fraction de tva que de connaître
l'ambition du gouvernement pour les cinq
années à venir
quelle sera la trajectoire budgétaire de
l'audiovisuel public inscrite dans les
contrats d'objectifs et de moyens est il
vrai que la signature des prochains
comme est repoussé à la fin 2023
pourquoi le gouvernement at il renoncé à
créer une commission indépendante pour
évaluer les besoins de l'audiovisuel
public comme le proposait le sénat voilà
les vraies questions auxquelles nous
n'avons pas de réponse il en est
malheureusement de même concernant les
missions et l'organisation de
l'audiovisuel public français qui est le
seul en europe à être éparpillés entre
autant d'acteurs aux moyens limités le
choix qui a été fait à l'assemblée
nationale de recourir à une fraction de
tva pour financer l'audiovisuel public
présente à cet égard un avantage
puisque c'est une solution provisoire
nous avons donc deux ans pour mener à
bien le chantier de la réforme de
l'audiovisuel public français c'est
pourquoi si nous pouvons adopter la
réforme de la cat telle qu'elle a été
modifiée par les députés puisqu'elle
assure le financement de l'audiovisuel
public nous devrons conditionner notre
soutien aux dispositions concernant
l'audiovisuel public français du projet
de loi de finances pour 2023 à la
présentation par le gouvernement d'un
calendrier précis d'une réforme globale
de l'audiovisuel public qui devra porter
à la fois sur le financement sur
l'émission sur l'organisation et sur la
stratégie numérique parce qu'il y a
urgence nous devons rechercher ensemble
les voies d'un audiovisuel public plus
efficace plus innovants et plus moderne
nous sommes déterminés à faire aboutir
cette réforme d'ici 2025 merci de votre
attention
merci chers collègues
la parole est là pas monsieur assouline
vous n'avez pas la parole la parole est
à monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président j'aurais
juste répondre à certain nombre
d'observations je vais être rapide il ya
débat qui va s'ouvrir sur l'audiovisuel
le public monsieur ghosn elle a rappelé
sur les collectivités locales et leur
financement sur le travail sur la
maîtrise des finances publiques et je
vois que sur tous les bancs de cette
assemblée il y a une véritable
préoccupation sur les finances publiques
tant mieux ce qui veut dire qu'il ne
faut pas sortir de cette assemblée avec
des dépenses inconsidérées à l'occasion
de ce plfr je propose que nous nous
fixons comme objectif de sortir avec un
déficit public maintenu à 5 % comme
c'est le cas que nous nous sommes fixés
avec desbriel attal mais je voudrais
juste faire quelques remarques sur cette
fameuse question la taxation des supers
profits puisque je crois que chaque
intervenant a pris la parole sur le
sujet pour répondre à quelques arguments
qui vont justifier des amendements qui
vont venir premier argument que j'ai
entendu cela va rapporter de l'argent
moi je suis très sceptique
d'abord parce que ça rapportera sap non
pas tant que vous le croyez j'ai entendu
deux milliards 3 milliards 4 milliards
mais encore faut-il qu'il y ait des
super profits qu'ils soient réalisés en
france
chacun sait que l'impôt dépend de
l'établissement stable et qu'il faut
qu'une entreprise et son établissement
en france pour qu'elles puissent être
taxées
or les profits dont vous parlez les
profits des compagnies pétrolières ou
d'autres se font à l'extérieur de la
france
donc on serait bien ennuyé si les
allemands voulaient nous dire vous avez
telle entreprise elle est en france elle
fait des profits en france elle fait des
bénéfices en france on va les récupérer
ses bénéfices et récupérer ses profits
et des taxes et on serait bien ennuyé si
l'entreprise américaine qui font des
profits en france nos amis américains
vous de nous dire mais nous allons
récupérer les bénéfices et les profits
qui ont été faits sur le territoire
français il est un principe intangible
de la fiscalité internationale c'est
l'établissement stable c'est bien ce qui
nous a amenés je le dis au passage à
soulever le problème la taxation des
gens de digital car l'énorme difficulté
des gens de digital et c'est plutôt à
eux qu'il faudrait s'intéresser qu'à nos
entreprises nationales c'est que non pas
d'établissement stable en france puisque
leurs activités et
désintermédiés et qu'elle ne repose sur
aucune présence physique donc je vois là
des superprofits qui dans le fond
devront générer aucune recette fiscale
pour le trésor public français
on me dit augmenter les impôts ça
rapporte toujours plus au trésor public
mais je pense que nous avons apporté la
preuve avec la baisse de l'impôt sur les
sociétés du contraire quand vous baisser
les impôts des entreprises les
entreprises créer plus de richesses et
l'imposition rapporte davantage nous
avons baisser l'impôt société je le dis
à l'intervenant qui a pris la parole
tout à l'heure en nous disant vous
ruiner les comptes publics en baissant
les impôts mais c'est faux pardon les
chiffres vous donne or nous avons
baisser l'impôt sur les sociétés de 33 3
à 25 % en cinq ans et les rochettes dies
sont passés de 50 milliards à 50 7
milliards c'est bien la preuve que quand
on augmente les impôts on baisse les
recettes on baisse la créativité du pays
on baisse la capacité à créer des
richesses quand on baisse les impôts en
revanche ont créé plus de prospérité
plus d'emplois et plus de recettes
fiscales pour la nation française c'est
bien pour ça que nous avons retenu cette
voie là je leur dis yes abc et ses
recettes compte augmenter mais dans le
fond derrière c'est toute une
philosophie est ce qu on veut produire
plus de richesses pour pouvoir mieux les
redistribuer ou est ce qu'on veut comme
certains ici qu'ont pris la parole
systématiquement taxer reprendre faire
contribuer avec des richesses qui sont
de moins en moins nombreux des emplois
qui sont de moins en moins nombreux un
chômage qui explose des recettes
sociales qui diminue et dans le fond un
appauvrissement généralisé du pays on a
déjà essayé je suggère de continuer dans
une autre voie qui est celle de la
création de richesse la prospérité et de
la création de l'emploi on me dira
ensuite mais d'autres états européens
l'ont fait mais je veux bien vous citer
l'allemagne mais l'allemagne s'est bien
gardée
d'imposer une taxe sur les super profits
de ces entreprises
la première économie européenne est
précisément celle qui n'est pas tombé
dans ce piège là les jo peut dire ont
fait leur la grande bretagne par exemple
pourtant pays libéral mais l'énorme
différence c'est qu'à grande bretagne
produit du pétrole sur son territoire
donc c'est normal qu effectivement elle
ait accès cette production puisqu'il y a
une production alors qu'en france on ne
produit pas de pétrole il est produit à
l'étranger et je rappelle qu'en termes
d'imposition
la france continue à voir un taux de
prélèvements obligatoires malgré les
efforts particulièrement louable de
cette majorité qui à baisser massivement
les impôts 52 milliards en cinq ans mais
malgré cette baisse a malgré cette
baisse de 52 milliards d'impôts sur cinq
ans le taux de prélèvements obligatoires
en france est de 47,5 en italie 43 en
allemagne de 41 en grande bretagne de 33
5%
donc je crois que la seule voie qui est
responsable et raisonnable pour notre
pays qui était accablé de taxes accablé
d'impôt accablé de prélèvements
obligatoires qui n'a eu sans cesse à la
bouche que de récupérer des richesses au
lieu de vouloir en produire c'est de
baisser les impôts de nos compatriotes
et de nos entreprises et je ne démordrai
pas de cette conviction la
alors l'ultime argument
l'ultime argument c'est de me dire c'est
juste
ben non moi je ne trouve pas que ce soit
d'imposer à travers vos amendements à
toutes les entreprises de france et de
navarre quelle que soit leur situation
dès lors qu'elles font des profits une
taxation supplémentaire je ne trouve pas
que ce soit juste
je pense que c'est inquiétant pour les
entreprises
inquiétant pour les chefs d'entreprise
inquiétant pour tous ceux qui créent des
richesses dans nos pays et dans le fond
inquiétant pour nos compatriotes même
qu'ils savent parfaitement que l'on
commence pas taxer des grandes
entreprises et qu'on finit toujours par
les d'accès eux mêmes
c'est précisément ce que nous voulons
éviter
alors vous avez cité des grands auteurs
et vous me dites que les impôts sont le
prix à payer pour une société civilisée
même si des impôts tu es vraiment le
alors la france serait de toutes les
nations du monde la plus civilisée de
tout je pense qu'il nous reste un effort
à faire
très bien allez allez chacun va se
calmer je vous rappelle que nous avons
maintenant 450 amendements à faire donc
pas chaque fois aller
tout le monde aura la parole dans le
calme allez la discussion générale est
close nous passons directement au texte
et j'ai d'abord l'article liminaire qui
ne portent pas d'amendement je mets au
voir cet article liminaire qui est pour
et qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté
avant